the georgia guide stones were bombed at
four in the morning blowing up about 30
or so percent of the structure
after this the government came in and
demolished what's left of it for those
that don't know the georgia guidestones
are considered a monument to globalism
they advocate for a global population of
500 million which some have argued as a
population control argument it argues
for eugenics quite literally and it's
also got some weird nonsense about the
infinite universe and just it's a really
creepy structure it was put up in the
1980s it was put up in 1980. some think
that it was just put up because it was
the height of the cold war and there's a
fear that nuclear war would wipe out
humanity and we needed guide stones so
that the remainder of humanity who
survived could rebuild in some kind of
fallout scenario
however
when there was no nuclear war some felt
like the guidestones were actually just
telling the elites what to do
and so they've been blown up they're
gone and maybe it's not the most
important story in the world but it is
big because this is a symbolic attack
someone there's a vehicle this video
footage released showing a vehicle pull
up they don't show what happens next but
then you see an explosion so i want to
know what's really going on
we've seen statues torn
torn down by the left
and now i can only assume that whoever
attacked this structure
is probably associated with
anti-globalist sentiments i don't know
that necessarily means right wing it
could be some far leftists because they
also have some time sentiments like that
but
who knows
we'll talk about that plus a whole bunch
of other stuff elon musk is chiming in
on the jordan peterson suspension and
alex berenson is his name right i'm
pronouncing that right berenson he's
been reinstated he was banned from
twitter over vaccine misinformation
twitter claimed filed a lawsuit
and he won
twitter settled with him gave him back
his account and apparently there may be
government involvement in what's going
on with twitter censorship elon musk
asked what's that all about and alex
said i can't say anything so this should
be really interesting if elon musk does
take over this platform assuming you
will he may actually expose some kind of
government
manipulation so we'll talk about all of
that but ladies and gentlemen before we
get started head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and download virtual shield the sponsor
of tonight's show you'll get a 50 off
lifetime discount a virtual private
network like virtual shield is a basic
layer of security for you while you
browse the web so if you're concerned
about
prying eyes maybe it's corporations just
spying on your data and we know they do
or packers maybe someone actually is
targeting you and you're not paranoid go
to
surfinginternetsafe.com virtual shield
their vpn service is compatible with all
devices it allows you to browse the web
safely securely and anonymously it lets
you uh
when you're using their vpn service your
traffic is routed through their secure
and encrypted servers that means that
any restrictions censorship blocks on
your internet are bypassed you can enjoy
browsing on a fast reliable secure and
always available network that is free
for 30 days available on mac windows
iphone ipad android or chrome virtual
shield does all the work for you your
entire connection becomes secure private
encrypted it routes your internet
through their advanced encrypted servers
across the globe to prevent even your
isp from spying on you they've got
personal family and business plans the
family plan includes 15 devices and the
business plan allows you to add as many
employees as you want virtual shield
will also completely encrypt your wi-fi
connection blocking hackers and everyone
else from accessing any of your data
head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com virtualshield is
our first sponsor ever they've stuck
with us all this time so we're really
grateful that they're here again surfing
internetsafe.com but don't forget go to
timcast.com
become a member
and directly support our work
we get a lot going on we are going to be
launching a bunch of shows we are going
to be building up this website very much
like any streaming service so tales from
the inverted world we are launching we
are we are uh maybe some people are
going to be happy about that but we're
launching it behind the paywall simply
because it's expensive to produce and we
want to keep making more of it so we're
going to have that be one of our first
shows outside of the tim cast irl after
hours show at 11 pm and we've got some
documentaries in the works as well as
potential uh even comedy skits short
films and other gags we're going to be
trying to make as many shows as possible
putting it up for timcast.com we're
going to be building tv apps mobile apps
all of that good stuff to make it like a
streaming service if you want to support
our work as we build culture go to
timcast.com become a member but don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends without further ado
joining us to discuss all of this is
rich barriss the people's pundit yeah
thanks for having me tim it's good to be
here who are you
ah that's uh that's a question for the
ages right no i'm a pollster i used to
do data journalism but now i'm most
known as a public pollster right now one
who uh
tries to get it right more than wrong
putting out a lot of data on say like
elections like how people are feeling
who they're going to vote for things
like that yeah definitely in issues in
between you know how do people feel
about what lawmakers are doing uh what's
wrong with the polling industry
uh which you know you could feel
throughout ever right considering this
this should be interesting too
considering that all of the polls have
been wrong yeah these past what three or
four cycles worse every time worse every
time yeah so this will be interesting to
talk about and i'd love to get your
thoughts on what you think is going to
happen in november so not such good news
maybe we'll see you know hopefully uh if
you want to see republicans take back
the house then you know you're hoping
that this is a temporary blip but uh you
know enthusiasm's dipping the lead on
the generic ballot for them was bigger
and so you know surprisingly big even
historically but all the metrics right i
think it's david axelrod i don't agree
with him too much but he did say
something the other day that that that's
right if you're a doctor and you're
looking at the chart right and all the
vital signs for the democrats look bad
you know we'll we'll get into all that
too so yeah thanks for coming we also
have mary morgan i'm back again she's
back hello i'm the co-host of pop
culture crisis on youtube we talk about
movies celebrity drama and just stuff
you might not hear about on tim cast irl
hi everyone oh ian crossland here good
to see you from ian crossland.net i'm
glad you're here rich because i have a
lot of issues i've had a lot of issues
with polling in general just the way
that it extrapolates they'll pull a
thousand people and then say that means
that a hundred thousand people feel
that aside what we were talking about
before the show about i don't know it
sounds like maybe as like entertainment
and politics are are colliding that
maybe people have seized the polls as a
means of propaganda i'd love to hear
more about it as we get into it yeah i
could talk about it for hours yeah i'm
very excited for this conversation i
think rich you're going to be great i
know that you've heard the term lies
darn lies and statistics i'm making it a
little family-friendly so hopefully you
can dispel some of that for us i'm back
from being sick thank you guys all for
being with us thank you chris yeah
i wasn't for example blowing anything up
in my absence no i really was not
feeling good but yeah i have seen that
theory and i love it so let's roll with
it let's get going all right let's jump
into this first story from the wall
street journal georgia guidestones
monument damaged embalming mysterious
granite structure which has drawn
tourists to rural towns since 1980 was
intentionally bombed authorities say
take a look at that photo man
dude
i'm really curious as to
what they did
who did it
why they did it the georgia guidestones
for those that aren't familiar are
called the monument to globalism
it's got these like 10 rules for for
creating a perfect society like maintain
the earth's population at 500 million
guide what is it what does it say guide
breeding or something guide reproduction
wisely
yeah i think guide reproduction actually
i think i have it i'm so curious who put
these up i am trying to
guide reproduction wisely so they've got
population control and eugenics right
there in the first two number three is
unite humanity with a living new
language what does that even mean i
thought that's was currency when i
mentioned currency at the beginning
because you said they didn't mention
currency in these 10
you know these 10 commandments or
whatever the hell they're supposed to be
but they say a living new language i
don't understand what that means other
than like a way of
communicating that's not words
is this
yeah something like tongue clicking his
answer finger snapping
more like changes
and grows something that changes and
grows language does
yeah that's what it almost doesn't make
sense so i have a question right so this
is
the kind of person who's going to be
ragging on the guide stones is not going
to be for the most part a democrat or
leftist they're probably going to shrug
and not know what it is there are
probably some anarcho-lefty types tanky
or communist types who don't like no
actually i take that back the tankies
probably love this stuff but there's
probably some anarcho-lefty types who
don't like the idea of globalism for
sure or at least the way they've
described it but typically it's going to
be more right-wing individuals who know
what this is and don't like it
so whoever did this maybe a false flag
maybe someone who's actually mad about
globalism my question is
the critics of this are predominantly
going to be right-wing is this the first
statue or monument that's been taken
down that was predominantly criticized
by the right
i mean we've seen christopher columbus
we've seen washington didn't complain
and whine about it and protest they just
took it down well i mean the left
just takes stuff down exactly like they
just show up randomly and throw ropes
and then rip it down sure but they make
a big show of it they don't do it in the
dead of night that's interesting or they
have the access though to
the power structure to take it
down yeah somebody's listening at a
university or somebody's listening
downtown because they have the ear of
the government the right doesn't really
they want to make the authority comply
with their orders yeah you know what you
know what i thought about what took so
long
honestly in the era that we're in oh for
real yeah in 08 this thing was
vandalized they wrote all 2014 it was
vandalized 2014 again i am isis right in
2014 something ridic but now in this era
uh where anti-globalism is mainstream
you know maybe back in the era of obama
it wasn't as mainstream as it is now so
almost 2000 it was mainstream the left
was protesting the world trade
organization well right yep in this way
yeah right in this way where it's almost
a political force you know where uh
they had some kind of symbol that they
needed to go after it's almost like this
one was at the top of that list
um
and there haven't been with all the
anger out there that i see even in pol
with all the anger out there there
hasn't been as many events as i thought
there would be or you would expect there
to be because it feels like people are
getting to a point where they're
bubbling over
and they there there's just nowhere for
them to go to air these grievances
anymore so eventually we're just going
to see stuff like this and that said we
don't know who did it yet but you know i
also think that klaus schwab is now in
the news pretty predominantly i didn't
even know he was two years ago world
economic forums all over the place the
black black rock black stone buying up
the houses is like trending on twitter
people are
are becoming aware that there is a
global corporation attempting to take
control of the united states and every
country on earth because the nationalist
governments are not capable of governing
themselves they need the corporation
according to klaus he's crazy he's
pretty good
yeah we have this tweet from the georgia
bureau of investigation showing this
vehicle the gbi is releasing
surveillance video from this morning's
explosion that destroyed the georgia
guide stones
strange
they just installed surveillance cameras
they recently did so shane cashman of
tales from the inverted world he he
wrote he went down to georgia he did
this big investigation he went to the
guidestones and he said they recently
put in these these floodlights and
cameras and then this happens
it's like
you you mentioned this just a second ago
why did it take so long right yeah and
then why did it happen right after the
cameras got installed and where's the
last of it where's the rest of it yeah
they show the car and they're like
here's the car but they don't show
anything else
they just show
an explosion
fortunately nobody was around nobody got
hurt but it's very strange and then they
show the rubble it looks like they lined
that stone with explosives like they
didn't just blow up the base of it it
looks like it got blown apart by like uh
yeah a bunch of explosions it looks
supposed to it it looks i mean i don't
want to use the word pro
but it doesn't that's not that doesn't
look like amateur hour to me i think it
actually looks amateur does it really
yeah because it only took out one of the
pillars
only because the blast didn't hit it if
you if if you look at it it looked like
it it went but down melon that could be
a sign it is amateur but right it
disproportionately came out one end if
they put it in the center
wouldn't it have taken out the center
column it looks like it was placed in
front of one yeah so it doesn't seem pro
at all unless they didn't expect it to
be hazardous i've never seen any break
and you know yeah hit one the middle
column hit one side more than the other
maybe they expected it to um you know
come out almost symmetrical but it
didn't i wonder why they decided to
demolish the rest of it
safety reasons i mean
it could be teetering it could collapse
you know so it looked pretty ragged
after lawsuits somebody
to maintain this like people would go
out and clean up and all that stuff the
guide stones actually had a bunch of
other features like if you looked
through at a certain angle or something
it could show you where the celestial
pole was
there was like math on it multiple
languages there was um
explanations for weights and
measurements why would they think this
would survive nuclear war i don't know
it's just stones right
it's so long
seriously but i mean think about it the
first two things are population control
eugenics yeah they're idiots yeah well
of course
let me read some of this for you one let
me let me show you two of the ones a
couple of them that i really love
all right let's see
um rule passion faith tradition and all
things with tempered reason okay i guess
that's not telling anyone anything
though because people all have different
ideas of what it means to be reasonable
but fine okay okay okay all right
unite humanity within with a living new
language that explains nothing to no one
no who who is going to see them go oh i
get it no no no but it gets better
so it says nine prize truth beauty love
seeking harmony with the infinite what
what what about pies
this is written by people that have
enough food to eat
for sure yup yup that's that's
absolutely it i like number seven
avoid petty laws and useless officials i
agree with that one let's go yeah they
stole number eight from thomas jefferson
they just they just twisted you know
they simplified what he said interesting
but that's what he used to say
you have no right that doesn't have an
equal or greater social duty as per
ian's point i'm imagining like nuclear
bombs fall
everything's wiped out and then some
dude with like a big beard and like a
stick walks up and he starts looking at
it and he like feels it and he goes oh
my stars turns around and starts
butchering some random person to eat
their corpses yeah really he's like
and then he's walks away and starts
hacking kids down
look at this let all this is number six
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court i dig it that's like a a global
corporation to
rule everyone as a court who like a u.s
who appoints the court exactly countries
i actually did that unfortunately i like
that one whose country is you know the
united states gets to do what it wants
we're sovereign
we you know stay out we mind our own
that goes without saying but instead of
war we have lost that's not how it works
we could try to do that but this just
gives us some weird
world court authority we should try to
have a court over shooting each other in
the face we have the u.n but we still
have like ukraine right i think war it's
inevitable because
even you know you have like uh you have
regular court you have civil court
someone will be like that guy kicked my
dog i'm gonna pay for it the guy says no
i didn't and then the other guy shows up
afterwards and punches him in the face
it's like you have we have courts these
disputes are still not always resolved
sometimes people still just get into a
fight so i'm i think world courts are a
good thing you know but you know inside
our country we do our thing
here's the issue
if the world court rules against you in
a way that's extremely unjust unless
you're israel you get war the world
course sometimes trans-pacific
partnerships investor state dispute
settlement clause where they were like a
a global arbiter will decide if if the
american people choose not to buy
malaysian oil a world tribunal will
decide if the american people can be
sued and have to pay with tax money to
pay this corporation back
here's the real issue that was a real
proposal the idea of some kind of global
federalism where the countries are
sovereign but there is a very weak
central power that can mediate
never gonna happen what will happen is
the moment you enact a world court it'll
be just like the us's the federal
government will keep usurping power and
then eventually you're in a globalist
authoritarian regime with their boot on
your neck
and then they're going to come to your
country and be like you lost the lawsuit
you can't use carbon anymore that's yeah
that's it's going to come down and
coalitions are going to come together to
to you know basically take the balance
of that court or try to influence it um
in the end it would probably end up just
like i mean i'm not saying it's not
worth trying but it might probably would
just end up
like the u.n does i mean we have it
depends i might be all right with this
if
if if we laid out the ground rules for
how who would be the arbiter so i don't
want some arbitration panel of elitists
up there making up the rules how would
we select these i think i think there's
no real way to do it reasonably because
people's values gosh dramatically the us
values clash with china in ways that are
just irreconcilable absolutely so what's
going to happen is i'll we'll use elon
musk as an example elon he's going to
buy twitter right he said you know i'm
moderate i think the good compromise is
that both sides are unhappy and i'm like
oh okay that's how things are
the left wants the right band completely
the right doesn't care the left speaks
so the compromise is okay we'll ban some
of the right well that's not fair
so actually we'll talk about this in a
minute too
the uh andrew schultz for instance yeah
you know he did this comedy bit netflix
apparently wanted him to pull some jokes
and he refused and it's like you listen
to it you're like oh he's making fun of
both sides and it's like yeah kind of
but not really because the right is okay
with the jokes this is the this is the
problem there's not going to be a fair
court you'll have the united states
being like we're totally cool that china
does their thing so long as they don't
come here then china's going to be like
we're not cool that they're doing their
thing and the world court's going to be
like okay we'll compromise the u.s has
to give up some of its rights that's how
it would play out unless you get
aggressive so i don't think i don't i
think
federalism the idea sounds beautiful
i don't know how you protect against
you know massive acceleration of the
coalescing of power
well the united states constitution is a
decent archetype for it
but
i don't know man to extrapolate that to
the globe it's like a fantasy of mine
yeah because you want to push your
values on other people who just don't or
not even push them on other people you
wanted others to see the value
of
the ideas that are in the constitution
but they they just some just won't it
would be pushing my values yeah it would
be forcefully providing american
democracy and republicanism to the world
overthrowing monarchs you know upending
totalitarian governments and giving the
people freedom yeah if they thought the
world was going to end in a nuclear
holocaust
so they made these stones
and said you got to keep 500 million
people that's the limit
and then
no nuclear holocaust happened
did they just decide you don't have to
have 500 million people anymore or do
they still hold that value and think
okay well now we got to do it i don't
think the 500 million should be set in
stone l-o-l just like oh in the
constitution one representative
represented 30 000 people that number
was destined to change they just wrote
it down there at the beginning because
that made sense at that moment at that
moment this doesn't say like and this
number can change they don't
they don't become seems arbitrary it is
500 million yeah some someone in the 80s
there's a lot of questions around who
actually put it up why why are there
questions around who put this up it was
put up in 1980 right yeah there's no way
there's not still that's just oh it's a
bunch of rich people okay that actually
creepy people who think they're smarter
than you and there and lies the big
problem oh there you go there's a video
going viral
um
it's a bunch of climate change activists
block a highway yeah and then this guy
gets out and he's like yo i gotta get to
work i'm on parole they're gonna lock me
up if i don't get to work and they'd
ignore him and then he walks up to the
person like give me one lane just let me
get to work oh i'm gonna get locked up
and they just tell him no like it's the
craziest thing to watch
this guy tweeted he's like i'll testify
on his bf i'm sorry that he got arrested
you know but whatever and then he's like
ask ask the activists organizers what we
should have done and i'm like you people
are evil that's what evil looks like
that they think they're smarter than you
they think they're better than you they
think they're more righteous than you
and when you beg them please i don't
want to go to prison they just they just
look you and say i don't care i
literally don't care it's fascinating
man
they think they're the righteous ones
the people who put up those stones are
exactly that
they think they know better than you and
they don't they never do that's why you
can't allow this kind of
authoritarianism because you get some
guy who's like i'm smarter than everyone
everyone melt down all your tools and
make iron
kill all the sparrows they're hurting
the crops and then you get famine and
destruction and starvation that's how it
goes
you get these people who are like i
think the farmers should own the farms
kill the landowners and then everyone
starves to death because the farmers
don't actually know how to run and
maintain the farm that's what happens
every time do not let these people who
think they're smarter you take over
decentralization is the only way to
properly maintain hmm well do we know if
the people who set these up actually did
any of the things that they were talking
about there's a lot of talk and a weird
monument no you don't know who set it up
yeah they're still alive probably yeah i
hope that they speak out i'm looking at
the wikipedia in 2008 the stones were
defaced with polyurethane paint with
explosions such as death to the new
world order
that's what it said in a way yeah and i
am isis or something in 2014 right yeah
i am isis goddess of love
yeah
the rest of that was that's right
because i just saw it a little bit ago
um
after seeing this happen uh i looked at
it and i i kind of remember some of
these stories
but i i don't i don't look at them as i
look at a story like this now or i
didn't because you know the struggle uh
that we're seeing in society right now i
guess uh
is not as
voc it's but more vocalized now it's
more in party platforms now than it was
before uh so i guess that's why my
initial thought was what it was
because we we know people have had these
frustrations in the past but now they're
coming to life
and
it's not a small you know they would be
kind of put off to the side awesome nut
cases vandalized it you could read how
the washington post tweeted this story
will summers how he laid it out on
twitter even before he got into anything
the first thing out of his mouth was you
know this has really been for a long
time the target of these right-wing
conspiracy nuts that's how you choose to
lead in this story
which goes to show you he's one of those
people
he's exact that is him and he gives his
hand away by even coming out with it
like that in the first place um
let's talk about the narrative exploding
outside of the actual narrative
exploding we have this other story here
uh alex berenson
so uh elon musk tweeted to alex berenson
a journalist can you say more about this
quote pressures that the government may
have placed on twitter
this is interesting alex barrison uh
berenson
was a uh is a journalist he was tweeting
about vaccines very skeptical and
talking about a lot of the data and then
he got suspended he filed a lawsuit
he won
nobody expected this to happen because
everyone believes that when you get
banned from twitter or whatever that you
file a lawsuit and then it gets thrown
out most of his suit did get thrown out
but breach of i think those breach of
contract which persisted
so alex says i wish i could elon musk
but the settlement with twitter prevents
me from doing so however in the near
future i hope to hope and expect to have
more to report
on a sub-stack post
talking about how he got his account
back he said
he says i need to add one thing the
settlement does not end my investigation
into the pressures that the government
may have placed on twitter to suspend my
account i will have more to say on that
issue in the near future i made a
promise to readers last month and i take
my promise promises to readers seriously
alex berenson
seems to have some kind of information
that the government is actively
pressuring twitter to engage in
censorship better watch out if elon musk
takes this company over it's going to be
really interesting to find out what
happens but how much do you want to bet
say it's october elon musk all the news
happens elon musk now owns twitter then
someone immediately says okay elon what
was going on and he goes i can't talk
about it how much do you want to bet
well if everyone i don't know how many
people read what he was talking about
last month but last month when uh he
discussed this on a sub stack he said
look i think we're getting close to an
agreement basically but any agreement i
make i promise will not exclude me from
being able to make this public anything
we may find in discovery surrounding
this issue and i think the reason for
that uh or why it's important is because
that gets to the crux of it and we had
those whistleblowers come out with the
disinformation government's bureau
whatever they were calling it where
initially the government said they
weren't really policing everyone's
misinformation this was only going to be
targeting russian disinformation and
security stuff but that wasn't true so
if the government you know i'm not a
lawyer but if from what we hear from
others um and viva and robert talk about
this a lot this is the that's the
linchpin so if they were pressuring
these social media companies that opens
up a whole new
pandora's box
this is what really bugs me about a lot
of this is that uh alex filed
he made a first amendment claim
and the judge was like you have no first
amendment claim because it's a private
company doing it not true we do know
there's a story out of california i
think it was judicial watch that exposed
us democrats were making requests on who
they wanted censored these are
government actors going to a private
company and using them as a cudgel so we
need a court to come in on first
amendment grounds and we need that
information how do you navigate this
when we know they're doing it but the
courts are like well it's a private
company it's like yes how do we get the
investigation to show the government is
going in and telling them to do these
things how do we get that information
i guess oh god a whistleblower is coming
out honestly
be brave go to project veritas yes or
some organization like veritas but
veritas is a great one yeah that's chuck
grassley senator grassley from iowa how
they how they got it there that was
government uh coming out and doing that
the private companies uh and project
veritas is great if i was working at one
of those they would be at the top of the
list because they've been doing so much
of this um but yeah i don't see any
reason why you couldn't go to a lawmaker
as well i mean eventually this has to be
fixed in the law the good news though
elon musk actively taking a role in
looking into these things
potentially
by october he may have twitter why do
you think by october that it was
reported that's when the settlement
should happen maybe even august so but
at some point soon i don't know
it just feels like people are clinging
to the idea and it's just not going to
happen oh mary you're so wrong young
enough elon musk will save us that's
right
all of our faith in one's twitter jesus
that's right
i agree with you mary i think there's a
lot of like hope that he's gonna save us
i don't think he cares i mean just the
guy and the government still has gag
orders like they can like you said put a
gag order they probably have one on
twitter right now that'll transfer
ownership it's on the company so here's
what i bet i bet there's a national
security letter the what i've seen
circulating is that the the feds have
national security interests in stopping
misinformation that's been the idea
that's going around if it's a national
security letter elon musk is going to
i'm going to buy this company he's going
to walk in and they're going to be like
here's what you've inherited and he's
going to look at it and go
can't do anything can't do anything and
it's going to be the same exact game so
you were saying what's his name um
barrett barrister barrisser baron
alex berenson he said on a sub stack he
was going to go public with everything
he immediately it happened and then
when he said i made a promise to my
readers what he's talking about is that
he said i will not make an a deal i will
not whatever arrangement we come to uh i
will not agree to it if it doesn't mean
that i can't publicly put out
information relating to that uh which is
important and then he agreed to a deal
and is no law and he said he can't put
out publicly this is what got me today
so maybe it's a government his
settlement pro this this settlement
prevents uh settlement with twitter
prevents me from doing so yeah and this
is this is what got me today uh the
security angle is gone i don't know tim
is this is his twitter account really
that important it's got it's got to be
that though the second maybe he thinks
when reading between the lines here he's
going to challenge that in court but
i'll tell you what if that's his plan
he's going to lose
he's going to lose without a doubt you
cannot beat those guys in court winning
when they pull that national security
card that's it it's over it's done no
judge no federal judge is going to uh
is going to be you know one of the first
to do that's the problem with
that's my first time contentment you
know
and i mean cut you off no go man the
first amendment argument that tim was
just lamenting they throw out all the
time that is the argument and they toss
it out uh you know all the time they
they throw that in the trash and they
talk about something that's on the
periphery or something and it just
drives me nuts i gotta i gotta call
shenanigans here i gotta call
shenanigans alex shenanigans
your settlement with twitter
what
your twitter account that's it
did he get money
my understanding is i got a twitter
account back
that's it we don't know the other
so i'm sorry you yo
i'm going to give alex the benefit of
the doubt and just say this
it may be he's currently investigating
and doesn't want to ruin his ability to
get more information
but this is not enough to come out and
be like i got my twitter account back
guys i can't tell you about the
corporate malfeasance yeah i'm like i'm
hoping there's another i'm opening this
you know what i would do
halfway right i would i would sit in
that papasan right there
i would take a camera i would grab all
of the paperwork i would take a cigar i
don't smoke cigars either but i would
sit down at the camera on and be like
ladies and gentlemen everything i'm not
allowed to talk about and i'd throw it
down and be like i'm i'm over it i
wouldn't i don't i don't stand for that
now it's easy to say because i don't
know
what happened it could be a national
security letter it could be that twitter
said look at what happened so so let me
bring this down for you
alex was told by an employee at twitter
that if he broke any of the rules they
would give him a warning
they banned him without giving him a
warning so he filed a breach of contract
first amendment and they said no no all
that stuff's out but the bridge of
contract's legit because they said
they'd give you a warning they didn't
banned you okay they can't do that
and so twitter issued a statement saying
we should not have banned him for this
it could be that the reason he wasn't
given any warnings despite them saying
is because national security letter feds
came in and said ban him for saying
these things and twitter was like
whatever you say government
and then didn't tell him why
when when these people get banned
there's no reason given it happens like
reason for band blank yeah that's what
happened to me they may have gone to him
and said we're gonna tell you why you
got banned we're gonna reinstate you but
you can't talk about it if we do this do
you agree yes boom national security
letter and then he's like okay
i wonder if they could
i bet you they could justify
these issues they have with elections uh
you know claims about elections i wonder
if they could justify that under a
security banner as well
because you know i popped up 45 minutes
after tucker i was lucky and reinstated
but when i was banned it was boom it was
gone and the only thing they were
anticipating was a report that we were
releasing um whether some of the claims
that you saw on twitter after the
election you know this many of this
people voted this many of that people
voted uh we were doing an investigation
on it it was imminent it was coming and
i was sitting home watching television
with my kids and i got a text from steve
ben and he's like you're a legend you're
gone
you know
are you are you back on now though i am
i went on uh
yeah i'll tell you tucker
the only one i had in my back how long
were you hollering were you banned for
uh about two days two days yeah it was
an error or something nope they just
they totally ignored me tim and i just
reappeared i got off of the show 45
minutes later you know i got maybe 20
minutes at the opening at tucker and
maybe by nine o'clock 905 i was just
magically talk about that were you
talking about the ban on tucker
yes that's what he he called uh to have
me on to talk about it here's what
here's what i think so you remember when
elon musk was like he's he secured the
deal and then all of a sudden all these
left accounts and celebrities lost
followers yeah tons of right wing and
libertarian accounts gained followers
i think it's obvious that there's some
kind of enron shenanigans going
shenanigans going on burning documents
destroying evidence something's
happening because they know elon's about
to come in
i think it involves the government i
think alex gave us that hint yeah just
that little teeny drop that he could say
without getting specifics and now he
can't say more because it involves the
government that could be taken out of
context and make it sound like you're
talking about alex jones about some
random
about oh right here
20 seconds
yeah that's mike the joke i posted is uh
there's a video going viral showing like
who's that he's at bugs yeah who's that
fat comedian oh no anna faris james
james they're eating crickets and ants
and stuff that's gross and then they're
like i just saw that and i was like the
year is 2037. alex jones is sworn in as
president his first act is to as an
executive order turning all the frogs
straight that's right but my you know
the joke is just
they show you these videos of people
eating bugs and i think people are going
to go and vote for trump yeah joe biden
all he needs to do to lose is come up
and be like come on man vote for me and
you'll be eating crickets people are
going to be like okay
i don't want to do that i think it's a
safe maybe not assumption but a safe
consideration that the government is
involved because it's twitter it's a
huge social media company they come in
with cease and desist orders they come
in with gag orders they say you need to
ban this person you're legally obligated
not to ever mention any anything about
this ever so they'll give the person a
no reason ban
and a story i was talking to this guy uh
when i was in austin and he said i i
think we're gonna have him on the show
he worked for the government he worked
in the trump administration and he said
the view of the national security
apparatus is that the meme stuff and
donald trump was undermining our
national security and must be stopped
and so what their goal is they want to
make the right present but politically
ineffective
cause just enough damage to the right so
they they can be present look like
they're putting up a fight but lose
because if you come in and just outright
ban everybody it creates ripples and
destabilizes the system so they're
trying to make it a 4951 scenario so the
democrats just slightly win every time
but it looks like the republicans are so
close yeah it disrupt equilibrium a
little bit and just make it a
that but that's the way it is in the
media right now i mean they almost have
and i say this uh you know i use this
analogy really i don't know if anybody
plays pool but it's almost like that i
would completely expect that because
it's almost like democrats have this
advantage everywhere else whether it's
the media the pollsters whatever um you
know it's like you're playing a game of
pool with somebody they want the six
if you don't spot them the six uh they
put up you know they they have a canary
or don't want to play the game at all
it's like they have this built-in
advantage um and when it comes to
messaging they lost that in 2016.
and their major lesson that they learned
from all of this was not that there are
people out there who have grievances
those grievances are legitimate maybe we
should listen to them that was not their
lesson the lesson they took from this
was let's control information we lost
control of the information flow those
memes i i've heard they take those
series they were effective
yeah yeah trump was memed into the
president you said the democrats had
control of the polls or had influence in
the polls as well what evidence have you
seen of that yeah i think without a
doubt um there's just no justification
with for some of the misses that we've
seen uh you know there there are a lot
of problems and we call them artifacts
you know depending on your methodology
that you create artifacts within polling
that uh will then result in problems you
know distortions in your results and
you'll be wrong but you can't be that
wrong that you're biden plus 17 in
wisconsin well yes that's not an
accident how did this happen the polls
were just so blatantly wrong yeah well
in 16 i'm getting to be i'm more of a
cynic now and i'm basically a full-blown
cynic but after 16 i really was naively
thinking
that if we just kept performing better
than everybody else they'll realize that
look i see your problems just pay
attention and and uh and adjust your
methodologies but they never did and in
18 everybody wanted to whitewash how bad
the senate polls were especially
looking at just the national generic
ballot vote and house vote for for the
house of representatives
but the presidency was coming and in
2020 obviously every presidential
election those are state level polls you
know your national poll almost doesn't
even matter so if you had a problem with
the state polls in the senate races in
18
why could you legitimately ignore that
moving into a presidential election
unless you're in you're intentionally
doing that was it who was it nate silver
he got he was like i did a good job
you're wrong and it's like his polls
were miserable he's he is a glorified
pole reader he is not really a modeler
he's a a glorified pole reader who has a
lot of money for i t on his site and dev
on his site and he's got some really
cool tools that you can look at and get
almost glamoured into thinking there's
something magical or special happening
there there's not there's not he he
reads polls like any news consumer can
read a poll and i constantly see him all
the time he's a polling guru the media
will call him he's never conducted a
poll in his life and i've told him
actually prove me wrong come to my
office i'll give you the reins you can
sit in front of the software i'll even
give you my sign in you show me how you
do this better but he would never do an
exercise like that he wouldn't know the
first thing to do so are the polls wrong
right now
uh yeah i mean there are some that are
doing the best job they can i have no
problem saying that i mean this the guys
at susquehanna they try their best jim
lee over there uh robert kahelia
trafalgar you know there are a lot of
people out there that are really trying
to just adjust to this changing world
the rest of them i gotta tell you i mean
these repeat offenders tim
they know they know they had a problem
the years before the morning consults
the reuters uh
the the yougov uh anyone who buys you
gov data they know they have these
problems so there is no legitimate
reason for them not to put a pause on
their polling after an election to
figure out i gotta re-tool here i gotta
figure out what i'm doing wrong nope
they go right into it yeah you were
saying that in the modern age that the
way people collect polling data has
changed like they used to do it all by
landline for instance and now people
don't have landlines so they got a text
but some people don't answer text so
they got to email like
what and but but people they they
realize that they're still just calling
landlines and that they're just not
changing course is that the problem yeah
and and this idea that the live caller
which is you know you the pollster hires
a call center most of them don't have
call centers themselves in-house so they
can't you know basically subcontract
them out to a vendor and uh there's a
lot of money in it so that's another
major problem obviously the cost of a
poll a live caller poll can be anywhere
and they hate it when i do this on shows
to just tell people how much it costs
but a live caller poll could be around
20 grand you know because each interview
is going to be about four or five bucks
to complete
and
somebody who's doing peer-to-peer text
messaging online panels they could do it
a lot cheaper so part of this is that
there's a boys club and if you evolve or
you force the industry to evolve
they're losing money
interesting what's a peer-to-peer method
oh that dumpster yeah actually i should
have i should have explained that look
you used to be able to just get
bombarded with taxes and most of the
time those were automated software's
that just hit you up like i would upload
a csv file to the software and your name
was on it your name was on it but
nobody's really on the other end 10dlc
is a new regulation for pollsters and
other people who want to text but it
hits pollsters hard you have got to have
a live agent on the other end of that so
maybe it could be tim who sends out 10
000 himself invites but if somebody's
there to respond you have to be able to
reply or you have it has to be a live
person on the other end is it that they
have to be able to reply or they have to
reply not have to be able the truth is
most of them don't uh which is kind of
defeats the purpose and is a problem
because this is 10 dlc is the last
attempt by the private sector to get
spam to your phone under control if they
don't the government's going to step in
and uh the cost will go up even more and
the regulations will get even more
strict uh but you have to register if
you do if your upholstery does
peer-to-peer you have to register you
have to do what is basically a
verification of your company and you are
legitimate and you're not just spam and
then there's like little tricks you have
to do make three or four you know so how
many how many times how many past
elections have we seen major errors from
the pollsters 2016 20 18 20 20 20. yeah
it's actually worse than that 2016 just
showed it because it was a presidential
miss and that doesn't normally happen
years before gallup was the gold
standard gallup was generally right
until they messed up in 2012 but 2016
was a real big miss and presidential
polls typically are more accurate than
other polls
so it got everybody's attention but
truth be told the exit polls have bombed
for many years two thousand and they
called florida for al gore uh
way too early because they believed the
exit poll data they did it again in o4
democrats for all of the people who
pined about january 6
democrats challenged the electors in the
senate in in 2004 based on this
ridiculous analysis that according to
the exit polls there is no way that john
kerry could lose the state of ohio well
exit polls are flawed yet they tried to
hold up electors over it so we saw uh in
2020
some safe democrat districts turned
republican yeah now you got the new york
times saying far right latinas with myra
flores that's ridiculous
what do you think is going to happen in
uh in november all right with myra
flores are saying it's a fluke she won a
special election because a bunch of
republicans came out but she won't win
again do you think it's going to be
better than is it going to be a red wave
red tsunami or is it going to be
maybe just get by a little bit yeah in
myra's case just to say uh that was a
low turnout older people who have more
uh ancestral connection to their voter
behavior so if your family is democratic
it's always harder for the older people
in the family to change that pattern of
behavior so in the november election
more younger people will be out so
they'll have less of a loyalty a strict
loyalty to to the partisan voting index
it's called and my that will help myra
so people are wrong with that really
yeah it will actually help her because
there'll be younger people who aren't so
loyal don't have this history voting
democrat um there'll be more of the the
shift that we see we've been seeing uh
you know the short answer with
republicans i think it's a foregone
conclusion they're going to take the
house but they're blowing the
opportunity to break their cap in the
house majority and i mean i can get into
that sounds like it's on purpose to be
honest me too i absolutely believe that
now but i will say we'll talk about that
but i just want to add one point you
know considering that um
mary here is the typical gen z i think i
think it's going to be a red wave across
the board because every gen zero
believes the same thing as marrying you
know just proves it
of course gen z is all catholic
conservatives
and female yep yep pretty representative
yes um i want to know do do you think
that uh inaccurate polling manipulates
uh public opinion
it does and is that really the intention
behind it behind not improving and
fundraising
and fundraising so if you're biden and
polls are starting to show a tightening
election
but then abc news for langer research
conducting it for abc news comes out
with that 17-point lead in wisconsin
well you know wisconsin's a must-win
state for donald trump so you stop
giving to donald trump oh he's going to
lose my guy's going to lose i'm not
going to give him 50 bucks this month um
and i i didn't believe that before but i
do now because it's more than just
they're not listening they're smearing
they're coming after me they're coming
after robert they're coming after jim um
it's not just all right these guys have
a different philosophy let's see who
performs better and at the end of the
day let your track record win no they
come at you they smear you and they
attack you so
that's not professional and it's not the
way this industry works in any other
arena
if you're if you polling is used for a
lot of different things we just care
about political polling more because
people people are you know in elections
uh but it's it maybe it's potential for
branding right it's the only area of
public polling where this happens well i
guess maybe it's not an error maybe
they're not screwing up maybe they're
intentionally lying in the polls to try
and trick people into voting a different
direction yeah i think that's definitely
happening on at least on some level but
there there are some people that have
just you know they've tried to retool to
him but they just keep screwing up
because it's
incompetence
it's a rock it you know it's tough it's
not easy to pull it's a hard job it is
so i try to give them leeway but at this
point
another thing i want to know um why are
presidential polls traditionally more
accurate
you know i
just higher stakes there's different
philosophies with that yeah i think
honestly you have people who are a
little bit more willing to tell you how
they're going to vote but also
this may change in the future because
the country used to be demographically
more similar like if you were in
ohio it didn't look all that different
from another rust belt state like
illinois for instance but now it does
demograph demographics are changing
quite a bit so i think that might change
but it
most people would probably tell you that
it's easier to go after larger groups
larger populations than it is to go
after populations that are a little bit
more you know it's it's more granular i
think uh error rates are bigger with
smaller groups people moved all over
because of covid we saw massive exodus
from california we saw people flocking
to florida and texas so this is going to
have a huge impact that pollsters
probably aren't prepared for maybe you
are
we ask about
you know we this is something i don't
know
my laura sometimes i say something on
you know live and she'll she'll be like
don't tell people that that's a secret
but we ask about generation were you
born in the state
are you second generation are you third
generation uh to try to catch that and
we also ask
more than just race we ask ethnicity if
you tell us you're white okay what would
you consider yourself german italian and
you could pick other maybe you're malty
that's fine but most which one do you
most identify with uh if you're hispanic
are you puerto rican are you cuban uh
are you mexican are you guatemalan i
mean what what is it asian same thing
chinese filipino japanese we're the only
ones who do this and some of that tim is
to try to catch stuff like that you know
there's there is the more you ask if you
can get some of this information it
should throw up red flags that maybe
you're missing something or there's
there's shift coming beneath your feet
that you got to try to catch
let me see let me try and uh we had this
story pulled up where did it go
there we go let's talk about this and
then we'll get into polls we have the
story from the new york post do you want
to read the headline you made a noise
ugh joe biden reportedly exports 5
million oil barrels despite u.s grass
prices how from our strategic oil
reserve
i i i thripped my mouth a little bit
when i saw this story i couldn't believe
it i couldn't believe that they would be
so stupid or just so evil
gas prices are through the roof they're
at record highs it's like i think 480
according to aaa five it hit five you
know a month ago people are struggling
they're dipping into their savings
they're running out of money
pete the supply chain is is crippled and
joe biden says yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
pull 20 million barrels for the
strategic reserve to help make lower
prices you know what i'm saying and then
we find out now he exported to europe
and asia so let me just simplify this
for you at a time when we don't have
enough and the prices are through the
roof biden gave some away
for what reason i i i don't know how you
look at a story like this and think that
the democrats could win anything
maybe he exported it at a profit
spiking the market somewhere else
there's one argument that but he's
trying to
spike the price of gas by selling below
market losing money intentionally to
force everyone else to compete with the
low price but he doesn't have enough oil
to do that that's what i was going to
say it it's not enough to drive
i think it has more to do with ukraine
oh well go ahead no yeah i think it's
it's
they want fuel for the war
and so i think that's what they're doing
you're wondering
in the ukraine yo joe you might be could
you did it
was engaged in illicit deals with
ukraine and now he's cutting checks by a
billion if he sends it to germany and
then germany sends theirs to ukraine we
essentially sent it to ukraine
it's called laundering you you also have
uh
putin
the movements from the russia russian
army we were all told he was going to go
into kiev but it was a failure so we had
to pull back if you look at where he is
i mean he's right over the shelter pods
so uh right i mean this
you know i don't know how you could look
at the russian military's position and
and conclude anything other than the
western media was lying to us and
absolutely putin absolutely had a plan
and insane propaganda all these videos
coming out of ukrainian soldiers with
cigars being like i just killed a bunch
of russians
the the pilot the ghost of kings ghost
i mean i was like day one that's
ridiculous look three or something i
like ukraine i have friends there
amazing country really enjoyed my time
there i'm sad to see what's happening
but i am sick of the lies and the
manipulation i think there's two things
one i think it is bad that putin invaded
i think he was losing the soft power
conflict so he wanted he he wants to
maintain control of crimea for the warm
water port he wants the eastern regions
for a lot of reasons there's politics
there's ideology there's partisanship
all that stuff
however
i think joe biden in a much bigger way
is beholden to ukraine for the illicit
deals that he was doing and that
explains it look people are like why
didn't vladimir putin invade when donald
trump was president
good question i think putin did fear
donald trump a little bit
why is all this going down now under joe
biden because i think joe biden was
cutting back room deals i'm sorry i'm
sorry i gotta pause i don't think i know
it because there's a video of joe biden
saying i said you're not getting the
money unless you fire the prosecutor
just so happens that prosecutor was
investigating the company where joe
biden's son was on the board so i'm not
saying that's why he fired the guy i'm
not going that far i'm saying
wouldn't any prosecutor just show that
to a jury and be like hey how about that
so now joe biden is cutting our taxpayer
dollars or i should say federal reserve
money by the billions what are that 70
billion dollars and then he's like we're
gonna spend hundreds of millions more
weapons and fuel now going to europe i
think they got him by the balls i think
joe biden was cutting dirty deals for
his son and now he has no choice but to
but to force us to be involved and i
don't think it's just joe biden i think
it's the bureaucratic state they've
invested too much in this and they won't
back down so the democrats are all on
board and then the low information
voters who are too stupid to realize
what's going on who couldn't tell you
where cutter was let alone the cutter
turkey pipeline are sitting there going
like yank yo biden you're a hero it's
lava ukrainia which is why it was such a
scandal the media held all of this from
the american people and electorate to
begin with because
this is why you care whether your
president is doing deals like this if if
obama had appointed him as the front man
for us ukraine relations and he used
that position to enrich his family to
enrich himself
you don't put people who are potentially
i don't want to use the
rachel maddow word but they can they can
they got you by the short and curlies
and you have no choice i mean the poll
has been going back to the polling
americans never wanted to do this they
never wanted to send lethal aid at one
point we barely had them teetering in
favor of sending humanitarian aid which
is just you know very ethical term you
know they just view it as money
but when you got to lethal force or
anything else
they were out they never and he just
ignored that so yeah have you ever seen
an unpopular president
ignore the will of the people and do
what joe biden does in these cases i
would argue no and you never see a
congressional democratic leadership any
majority who has an unpopular president
just ignore the unpopularity of these
moves and just full steam ahead
as if there's no political repercussions
they just don't care it looks like
something else it's different that's not
how it works you know
presidents with 37 approval ratings
don't have political crowd this is this
is the perfect example of the ship hit
the iceberg and the elites are stealing
as much fine china and silverware as
they can before running to the lifeboats
and everyone's going what what what are
you doing and they're like slavo
ukrainia and you're like yeah okay and
then they jump on the lifeboats and
there and then when we fix the boat
they'll be like oh
oh i found all this silverware that
someone was trying to steal crazy that's
correct let me back into my room
tomorrow i i think that's one way to put
it i wouldn't go so far as to say the
ship sinks and we're all just adrift and
they're riding away on the lifeboats
waving the silverware at us i think
what's likely to happen is that
the ship sinks partially it's crippled
we're all still on it life sucks a bit
and then we see them off in the distance
partying cheering with china
pouring the champagne and being like
there you go
and then human ingenuity kicks in and
we're like well
we evolved because we have to let's fix
this boat question is what do we do we
hunt them down do we do we sail after
these criminals and punish them or do we
just live on with our daily lives and
make life better
i like your outcome better all right i
do it's more optimistic you know but it
is true um i think we'll be okay yeah i
think there's a way of writing itself
tim but i think bad things are ahead i
think i think you look at stories like
this and i'm just surprised they would
even dare admit it yeah
you know just
joe biden is effectively looking you in
the eyes american people and saying hey
man five bucks a gallon
so what i gave your strategic oil
reserves away
the oil that we have saved for a rainy
day not for high prices but for when
we're at war or there's a major shortage
he's just giving it away oh maybe he
considers us at war maybe that's what
this is i wonder who descendants was
true who did he send it to
it was exported to europe and asia it
was sold it was transported companies
were involved look i think the official
explanation is that they were hoping to
shock the market into lower prices it's
just massively stupid
i don't i don't care if that was the
case that's not what strategic oil
reserves are for exactly
this is this reeks of joe biden is
dragging the united states into a
conflict with russia
nato is involved us intelligence is
aiding the ukrainians and they're just
pretending like they didn't unilaterally
unilaterally declare war yeah that's
what they do when that his advisor came
out like three or four days ago or last
week i think and said you know this is
all for he didn't use liberal economic
order he used the do you remember
liberal world liberal world order also
known as the liberal economic order
us-led global rules-based economy
there's all these names for it but it
was pretty clear that that's why we're
suffering right now but then he has the
audacity today to go out
and make the remarks that he makes and
he chuckles about i call it putin
inflation as if anyone believes that
nobody believes that dude he did a talk
where he was like it's russia russia
russia russia like a brady bunch brady
bunch yup marsha marsha they they i
think at this point he knows he's done
and and they i i think the democrats
were like look we're gonna run biden
against trump we're gonna get obama
nostalgia
then we put all of our sins upon him and
sacrifices yeah i think all of the
really awful things they wanted to do
they put on buy-in so that they get them
out and then they can be like oh geez oh
you know we'll come and fix it
i don't see how uh
any democrat could win like 24 and 24.
we've pulled them all save a miracle had
their problem because i i think you're
right about that they were gonna just
sacrifice him and you know put kamala
right in there uh because these people
really believe she was likable or would
be like i kid you not that's the
craziest thing the bubble these people
live in they really thought she was
going to be like the second
talk
she basically never got to iowa yet
somehow the general electorate is going
to fall in love with her so now they're
in this position we've pulled them all
kamala pete buddha judge hillary i last
month i had to bring back hillary
clinton no i don't
because but nobody's viable trump is
killing them all what about
yeah you know what that's the next one
i'm going to do because i normally would
say
and i'm going to be careful here she's a
lot like kamala
until you see her she's all shiny and
the media paints her up but the minute
you really focus on her she's not
likeable she's not
do you think she's nasty she's the
authoritarian in that family
all that matters is nc speech he gave
for biden i mean they painted over it
what a beautiful speech but just go back
and watch it
yourself and look at her mannerisms
notice by the way she'll never mention
kamala because she hates kamala harris
how funny would it be if they like the
only person they have is michelle obama
so like she's coming out you've got to
shoot me she walks out with a big old
smile and she's waving and then she goes
this country is a bunch of disgusting
deplorables
that's rush them how do you know she
hates kamal harris
uh
you survive again no she hates kamala
harris um
and actually obama doesn't like biden i
mean these relationships because obama
is quoted as saying never under
underestimate joe biden's ability to f
things up she feels like their uh her
husband kind of made a fool of her a
little bit and then it he he did this
and i'm gonna walk the line here but i'm
gonna do it
there's like
rumors
and uh he made this public statement
about how she was the most attractive
attorney general in the country which
apparently michelle didn't like very
much oh i see then they're
generally traveling on paradise separate
vacations
and
drama
obama drama
obama is definitely not no drama obama's
got drama and uh you know he's he's a
cool cat in front of the camera you know
you got to give it to him uh but his
wife is not and i'm telling you when
that comes out on camera and
i know what happened to the american
people i know exactly what happened
they're at a fundraiser kamala's sitting
there and she's drinking obama walks up
and they're talking and he goes uh you
know humble
i blew up a bunch of kids when i was
president and she's like
how many kids did you blow up
she was like wow
wow she's like i also love torturing
people he was like we got something in
common
yeah kamala harris man when tulsi
gabbard roasted her on the dnc stage it
was one of the best moments in political
history it well and she's got a
reputation which michelle obama knew
about well before the rest of the
country did
and you know i mean it is
she's got a reputation oh yeah one way
to put it is that a real is that oh it's
real she basically that she slept away
to the top she did or well
that's the rumor she selected willie
brown's top yeah she slept with people
that she was working with you know then
got promoted yes and got to and then got
like hand-picked by the guy who runs the
machine out there who was her boyfriend
30 years or elder i think right
something like that willie brown um
and sadly when she first got the top cop
job in that city he was a decent guy
uh but willie just wanted to put his
girl in there so they they destroyed
this guy and when she did she broke uh
fundraising laws and you know basically
had to pay a small fine because of her
relationship with willy i mean he got
her out
it's it's bad you know i i think what
actually happened and i don't blame
obama for this you know kamala got real
close whispered in his ear tell me about
all the kids you blew up he was like oh
boy oh my god i was around that was it
he couldn't handle it he was just like
well there was one kid and then there's
another kid shell did not like actually
all the military age males that we blew
up
michelle's like what are you on the
phone with her for three hours at night
about it yeah he's got a lot more about
the kids so there's a texting there was
a thing called the disposition matrix
you're familiar with it no it's uh it's
the disposition matrix is the formal
name for obama's kill list yes he was
given uh
it was called like baseball cards every
tuesday and he would select who to kill
yikes so he's he's he's in his you know
he's in his bed and he's sitting on his
stomach but he's kicking his feet and
he's like well we had the anwar unlucky
blow him up uh he was american citizen
no charger trail uh and then i blooped
his son and then he starts listing all
people just down the list and camel's
like oh say more names who else did you
blow up what about julian assange locked
him in a prison
yeah you know that was all the
authoritarian wet dreams yeah that was
one of the worst stories of his
presidency
yeah i mean collateral you know whoops
collateral yeah it was me either but
that's those for those that argue yeah
people should know
uh anwar al-awlaki was a jihadi was an
american citizen and so uh we blew him
up that was it the drone strike killed
him without charge or trial wow and uh
it vaporized into somalia right i think
it was in somalia yeah they or was it in
yemen it was in yemen
i think it was yemen yeah anwar was in
yemen i think oh i thought abdulrahman
was in yemen uh then they said i thought
they both were right it might have been
yeah so uh onward was an american
citizen who was killed by obama that's
murder i don't know
yeah was killed in yemen for sure okay
yemen that's just murder you don't get
to be like it's a military operation
targeting an american citizen no we have
charge or trial you can't execute
somebody who's an american citizen let
alone i don't like the fact they do it
to anybody abdulrahman al-laki was a 16
year old american citizen who was
vacationing in yemen visiting his
grandparents blew up a civilian
restaurant with a drone strike and went
oops i don't buy it
my opinion is obama was telling
everybody if you screw with us i will
murder your kids yeah that's what he did
yeah when i was intentionally not fine i
mean tim this is a guy
who worked with the bush this is
somebody and i don't want to say work
with the bush administration but after 9
11 the bush state department was looking
around for influential imams to help
them reach out to the muslim community
amwa avalaki was one of
the invite
he got invited to that uh initial
you know dinner come come hang out let's
all get together figure out how to do
outreach it was an imam in virginia so
how did he get from
you know you're going to be our point
man
to the muslim american community in the
dc suburbs how did you go from that to
being public enemy number one what
happened in the time period
you know where bush cut him loose and
we're supposed to believe his kid died
an accident
it's too it's i'll tell you this and
then no trump
if anyone in this country accidentally
kill the sixteen year old and uh
civilian restaurant would they be in
prison right you betcha right not obama
he can't kill him skate it out he killed
the son two weeks after he killed the
dad that's right blowing up a civilian
restaurant yeah they've been accountable
eating outside at a civilian restaurant
in yemen that's right and the obama
administration ordered a drone strike
blowing them up so technically this
position could you imagine if trump did
that they went nuts when he killed assam
solomony trump had a commando raid that
killed abdulrahman's younger sister
so was there a legitimate target in that
though or there's a legitimate target in
in the claims of the abdulrahman
al-awlaki situation now the one thing i
will say is
i think all of it demands an
investigation if trump ordered a
commando raid and a seven-year-old
american girl was killed i want to see
absolutely however
with abdulrahman al-laqi this is
definitive we have the reports we have
the official statements from the u.s
government they know they did it they
admit they did it with donald trump and
the seven-year-old uh sister of uh
abdulrahman
we have
family testimony that this is actually
what happened so no real hard evidence
other than claims made by people who are
there either way i'd love to see an
inquiry i don't i don't think we should
sit back and allow the executive branch
to just be like we killed somebody we
were accused we ignore it i'm not saying
put trump on trial and scream and wave
your arms in the air i'm saying let's
get a real answer that's what that was
you mess up i'm also i'm also not gonna
play this game where you know i say oh
okay well you know trump did it no no
obama was was the one who who killed
these people and i think it was four
american citizens then we can have we
could have a discussion about what
happened with trump in a commando raid
but i want to i want to start with obama
first and not lose track of things not
that i think anyone's anything will ever
happen
but justifying it's it's that's a
dangerous line justifying uh he was just
a terrorist you know he was al qaeda's
main propaganda guy he uh he ran inspire
look at january 6th everything that's
going on you could be the domestic
terrorist tomorrow i could be the
domestic terrorist tomorrow and that was
just completely blown over
you know we all went on with our lives
and don't think that the u.s government
is beyond this stuff we've we've seen it
we've seen what happened with um what
was it in in philadelphia was the cops
blew up that neighborhood
would you remember what that was called
i don't i don't but
you know there's plenty of examples of
these kent state
ruby ridge oh man that's right even wake
up i was just at waco too oh brutal
stuff i went well let's let's
let's uh let's let's let's um
i guess last 1985 philadelphia bombing
is this it yeah city changed the city
forever
this is like something that has not got
a lot of attention i don't know oh that
gets a lot of attention all the time it
comes up regularly but let's let's let's
do this let's um let's laugh as we watch
the demise i have this tweet from
leftism for you
just another day in new york city insane
at belfry's and nyc
some women got angry that extra sauce
cost i think was a dollar fifty and so
they just ransacked the whole place
jumping over smashing everything
attacking people and just destroying
everything why is there so many videos
like this
something is happening in places like
new york get out of the city is the only
thing i can say
the official story apparently yeah okay
1.75
women destroy manhattan business
leaving employees bloodied for 1.75
couldn't get their extra sauce
what's happening
um people are disarmed and unable to
defend themselves the first thing i saw
when i watched this video i was thinking
about it from the person's perspective
that was being attacked and having their
their business destroyed or whoever they
were what if they were armed and they
fired at the attackers would that have
been justified go to jail yeah in new
york you could have a major problem um
i personally know somebody who uh
had a real if the governor himself
didn't get involved in new jersey it
would have went a lot different for him
and that was defending himself and his
wife
against an attacker they wanted him to
use equal force in his own home came
home from work but he didn't use equal
force uh or at least attempt that's an
insane it's crazy it's what define equal
force exactly how do you know if the guy
in front of us is a black belt or not
right brazilian jiu jitsu mma oh well
your officer i shot him because i saw
his ears he had cauliflower ears that
justified equal force right how do you
have no you have no idea when i when
when we had uh back in when i was in
jersey we had a crazy peter guy try to
break in like
and you know he's like told my story and
like we hear it's like three in the
morning i call the cops i'm like yo and
the cop said to me he's like if it were
me i'd answer the door with a shotgun
and i was like okay so i went on my
journey trying to figure out how to get
a gun it was very difficult i was lied
to left and right finally figured out
how to get one and then i was sold
basically the way it was broken down to
me
if you're in your house
someone breaks in
in new jersey you have to flee your home
yeah you have to jump out the window or
whatever get away you can't only if
you're cornered and then i'm like okay
how do you define corner i don't know
you're gonna get arrested you're gonna
get charged with murder and then you're
going to argue to the jury why it wasn't
actually murder yes so it's like okay so
a guy can break to my house and i'm i
can't defend myself without getting
charged with felonies and arrested
that's right
i'm leaving this day that's what i said
i'm out in this case it was uh he was
being i mean he was messed up he was
being brutally assaulted with a piece of
firewood that was by the fireplace the
guy just took it and just started you
know viciously beating him over the head
with it cracking his face so he was a
plumber and he took uh
one of the box cutter knives he still
let his tool belt on he came home from
work and he found the guy in there with
his wife
and assaulting her wow and he was not as
strong as the guy
so he he got the guy was on top of him
hitting him with wood he took a box
cutter they arrested him charged him he
had a later demonstrate that he was
jersey right yes this is the annoying
thing i had a lot of people say to me no
tim you're wrong new jersey's partial
castle doctrine you can defend yourself
in your own home no no no it's not it's
crazy that anyone would think new jersey
what do they call one of the evil seven
that's what gun owners call them uh what
would allow this no no you're in your
home
and so the way the house we had was set
up is the my room there's no way out you
jump out the window from the second
floor so if someone broke in i'm like i
got one path i have no choice so i see
someone breaking in my house
and i'm supposed to stop and and try and
discern do they have a weapon
are they gonna attack me in my own home
like i said just wait and find out
that's new jersey for you you need the
governor to come in and try to basically
help you
based on the castle doctrine rule no no
lawyer is going to walk into a court and
argue that to get you off it was crazy
um and that story is a really tragic
ending by the way oh the whole family
was destroyed over it it was just
terrible west virginia is a bit
different
a little bit west virginia
it's it's actually kind of crazy
depending on who you ask obviously you
want to be reasonable but if you're out
on your property in the middle of the
night and someone's trespassing on your
land you are in many circumstances
justified in using lethal force against
them now not entirely it depends on uh
standing your ground someone's
trespassing you have no assumption like
you have no no duty to make assumptions
about who they are what they're doing if
they're on your property late at night
you feel threatened now it's during the
day and someone walking on your land you
have to be like hey get off leave now or
else
but uh maryland's a bit better not that
great not much better than new jersey
so i we we've talked about all this
stuff in maryland
you have it you don't have a duty to
retreat from your home but you do have a
duty to retreat to your home
so if you're outside and someone starts
walking on the property you have to tell
them to leave if they don't you go into
your house go inside okay if they then
try to enter you are justified using
force and i think the reason this
probably happens because maryland
although it is still a very awful gun
gun right state you still have western
uh western maryland which wants to be
west virginia in west virginia it's
basically were you reasonable in trying
to avoid harm you don't have to retreat
to your house it's your property we're
not going to make assumptions and that
makes sense too and the issue is in west
virginia your property is probably a big
piece of land yeah so if you're on
different situations right if you're on
10 acres of open land and you're you
know doing something on your property
you can't necessarily retreat to your
house so that's why it's a bit different
but west virginia is a bit better and
then you get like texas and florida
florida florida basically like make more
than make my day laws or something yeah
make my day you're basically uh
somebody's walking on your yard they
don't respond you're good to put one in
their left cheek at least you know i
mean it's it's you know
but again there have been pushes um in
the last 10 years especially saw it with
trayvon martin that was a national case
they tried to come after the stand your
ground but george zimmerman was
acquitted because he was in that case
it's a perfect example they felt like he
was reasonably
he had a reasonable fear that his life
was in danger well he was on the ground
he was getting his head punched in the
face repeatedly that's right and the
media lied about everything as they
always do and then you actually ended up
seeing this in the surveillance footage
one we learned zimmerman was a mexican
guy and his face was bloodied up i
remember that that was that zimmerman
was following trayvon martin and then
martin was like hey stop following me
and the guy was like i have a reason to
suspect you're doing something and then
trayvon jumped on him
basically
we don't know exactly what happened we
know that zimmerman was like driving in
his truck he sees trayvon martin
yeah like walking through these yards
and then a confrontation ensued
he called 911 and said hey this guy
looks pretty suspicious he's like
wearing a hoodie and then they said you
know describe him to us
nbc takes that audio and removes the
questioning from the 9-1-1 so you just
hear zimmerman being like he's
suspicious he looks black even though
it's not what he said they asked him
a fight broke out for some reason
trayvon had him on the ground and he was
doing what's called a ground and pound
where he was pummeling him yeah and then
the ref will pull you off in mma
zimmerman on the ground because that
means the fight's over at that exactly
zimmerman on the ground pulled out his
gun and fired into his chest
and then the media lied about everything
yeah and they claimed that he was a
racist white guy profiling a black
teenager and it's like zimmerman's
mexican it's a florida neighborhood
watch thing
uh trayvon was was was beating him up
you know what i think happened i think
zimmerman was overzealous i think he was
probably like i'm neighborhood watch
yeah trayvon martin was like
disrespected and insulted by it said
screw you who are you you can't tell me
what to do two guys got into a fight one
guy had a gun that's what happens this
narrative about a racist white guy it's
like zimmerman wasn't even a cop he was
just totally irrelevant so that's the
narrative they run with and now i saw
this thing about like it's like gen z
and millennials running for office and
then it's one guy and he was like a
racist white man killed trayvon martin
and that woke me up and i'm like this
dude doesn't even read he just got memes
off the internet he believes the memes
and now we've got to deal with
governance based on me he's having that
dream where he woke up in his dream but
he's still sleeping but he thinks he
woke up but he's like but why is reality
so still so weird because you're still
sleeping bro so look these these these
uh new york is well what's this my
reason i brought it up do you think that
these big cities are going to eventually
start lacking gun laws and be like we
need the civilians to step up and help
us police our city because the cops
can't do it i saw a philadelphia almost
like a raid where there's like a hundred
or more people on the street just
screaming and fighting and like
four cops i think were present
completely uncapable i mean what at some
point you tap the militia and you're
like yo we need help san francisco they
were raiding those uh those stores they
just run in and steal everything and run
off yeah you can't
civilization break it down man new york
has a history of that too they had uh
and the name is escaping me but they
would run around with the red on
something angels i think they were
called and they were basically
really when uh mayor
started with a d before giuliani uh the
the city was a wreck so the town came
you know the city each borough had their
own angels that would come and they man
they police the subways i remember them
actually remember
yes that's coming back yeah it's scary
and that's my that was my point this
stuff will guardian angels the guardian
angels thank you and one of them even
ran for mayor once yeah it was recently
just a non-profit international
volunteer organization they did that
they did the job they would affect
citizens arrests and everything so did
the mayor ask for their help nope they
just stood up and we're like did it
militia
they just well you know the story of the
subway vigilante right
i don't know no so uh do you know the
story i do yeah i mean i was young but
it was big news you were in new york at
the time yeah do you want to tell the
story no i just remember this guy was
running around basically uh you know
being
well it was one major incident it was it
was one guy right it didn't turn out to
be a group it was one guy and he was on
the subway
and he i think he shot what was it three
or five people
uh and then he was accused
of being racist that he racially
profiled some black men and shot him he
said he was being mugged and so he
defended himself with an illegal weapon
i think i think it might be
no the gun was illegal
i think so yeah so you have people both
sides of the aisle you know constantly
outside but he was a folk hero in new
york yeah the crime was sobering shirts
yeah people were just like yay fight
back the crime was unassuming white guy
you know like middle right middle aged i
think he was i mean very unassuming and
then people of course looked at him like
yeah this guy is trying to be a hero he
was basically what they did to richard
jewell the left tried to do to him yeah
you know what's richard jewel he was a
security guard uh in atlanta when the
bombing went off during what the
olympics or something right i think so
yeah and they made a movie about it they
did to make a movie about them uh they
tried accusing him of being the bombers
yeah he was the guy
he was actually the hero
he was the hero who cleared the area out
i mean the media killed this man yeah
they killed him they ran his health into
the ground and his heart literally gave
up that's that's something it was yeah
the centennial olympic park
1996 summer olympics that's right it was
security for the music that was going on
there at the time and he saw suspicious
pack every by the way all the cops there
were feds around they always
mocked him said he's the overzealous cop
wannabe he was a deputy in a neighboring
town at one point but he was right about
that book back he was right and he
cleared everybody out and he saved who
knows how many lies but the feds had
nowhere to start
so they looked right at the
they looked right at richard jewell they
realized the fed's fault before it was
the met the media this is one of the
reasons the country's falling apart i
made a video man i think it's been four
years
talking about why men are no longer
helping women and children i read this
story about a guy who was in a store
and this woman this female journalist
saw him
walk walking down like the isle there's
a little kid who's crying and alone
she looks to this guy he stops turns
around and immediately runs away
she sees people come up to help the kid
once she realizes the kid's safe she
runs up to the guy and asks him why
didn't you help this kid and he says are
you kidding i'd be accused of being the
kidnapper or something i'm not going
anywhere near that kid yeah and she was
like this man saw a child in distress
and ran away because he would be accused
and so there was another story where a
woman was being beaten in the subway and
everyone just watched and then she got
really mad she's like why aren't the men
standing up and protecting me it's like
because nobody wants to be involved
because the legal ramifications are you
go to jail if you try and stop them
this was four years ago now look at new
york city yeah what would happen you got
these women smashing up this rest this
this burger place or whatever belfries
whatever it is and they're ripping
things apart they're throwing things
this guy
what would he what would happen if he
took any
any weapon to defend himself
they'd go crazier they'd get even more
angry they'd attack him even more you'd
be a frenzy the guys would then be like
whoa oh and then more people would jump
in what if he then pulled out a gun
if somebody just pulled a gun you get a
shootout
then if this guy defended himself not
only that the city would probably come
after him so he does nothing these three
women i guess have been arrested and
charged over over what happened but
this is but no it's not something if you
break into my place of business and
you're doing this i should be allowed to
stop you for sure that's my opinion not
new york
it's like the protests and
in the summer of love like you had to
just put up with your business getting
attacked
otherwise
the cause is always more important than
people there's a meme they're like
people keep saying it's it's i i
understand it's wrong that a black man
lost his life but but it's wrong that
buildings are being destroyed and you
should be saying i understand it's wrong
the buildings are destroyed but it's
worse that a black man lost his life and
i'm like uh how about this we all agree
that innocent and unarmed people should
not be killed that doesn't justify you
burning down or looting the neighborhood
it has nothing to do with each other
this is the game they play
they'll what's the argument for this
stuff the looting and the chaos and the
destruction what's the argument yeah
normally they have some kind of social
justice angle that they want to then
with the greater good there's no greater
good here there's a dollar 75 for extra
sauce why why isn't the right leading
with this story
why is the right always just responding
they are never re i was just going to
say they're never really proactive
that's what separates i would say i
think why ron desantis is really
starting to gain traction with some
people but
he's still reactive yeah
i like him but he's starting to get a
little bit more reactive but for the
first year or so he was seeing like he
understood they got to call the shots
called the shots uh but the right
doesn't do that what we didn't even
trump
syndrome kind of thing even if
republicans win in november they're not
going to do anything i don't think they
will tim honestly we've been down this
road before and i don't mean to get you
know i don't mean to be johnny raincloud
to some of you at home but look 2010.
give us the house we'll repeal obamacare
oh yeah right we need the senate we need
the senate give it to us in 2014 we'll
we'll get it done
then they finally get a president
willing to sign it and they fold
t uh paul ryan right to hand it i will
never forget that because i knew he was
lying i knew because people in the
freedom caucus basically uh were having
a canary over his plan which he barely
showed to them at this time but he went
right to sean additi sat right in the
chair looked right in right in the eyes
we have a consensus plan and hannity was
like
you have a consensus we have a consensus
people on the
in the other room were jumping up and
down they knew he was lying because they
barely had showed him a peek of their
plan and it was the more moderate plan
that was never going to go you know sell
with the freedom caucus uh so this i see
this happening all over again the
democrats say we want universal health
care a sweeping overhaul the entire
medical system in this country that
would radically transform 20 of the
economy and republicans say we'll give
you some then the left goes the
republicans are blocking us from our
dreams and it's like bro you're
steamrolling the entire country then
they're like we want gun control we want
to ban all these guns republicans go
we'll ban some of them with you and the
democrats go the republicans are
obstructing our goals and meanwhile i'm
sitting here like can we just repeal
these gun laws
not a single person
maybe i think lauren bobert perhaps
we've had a few people from the freedom
caucus express their their willingness
to repeal the nfa and other
unconstitutional gun laws but in the end
you get what three to five people who
are like yeah those gun laws do actually
infringe upon your right to keep and
bear arms i'll do something about that
but 90 of republicans are just like no
we'll give democrats everything they
want just slowly i used to be kind of
for universal healthcare i thought it
was an interesting idea um now i think
of chronic illness as like on the
individual like if someone overeats or
eats a lot of sugar and then they get
diabetes and then they have to go to the
hospital and spend 30 grand a year on
medicine i don't want to pay for that
person's laziness or inability to
control their own diet like there are
some chronic systems where the person
maybe is born with some degenerative
disease or neural
then i'm talking that's a different
story but i am not here to placate
gluttony but also our options for what
we're eating have been turned into
poison so that's not anyone's fault well
it's the pharmaceutical industry working
with the
the food industry so they feed you
sickening foods and then give you the
medicines it's hard to place blame on
the individual sort of i mean look i
don't blame them i just don't want to
pay for it i i agree with you that our
food choices have become trash the
nutritional diets
the nutritional density of our food has
gone down quite a bit so people are
eating on eating a lot of starches and
salts and other other garbage food yeah
but
you still can do better dietary
ignorance is that's an interesting idea
is is the person that's overeating it
with a food pyramid that has bread on
the bottom
like i just don't think it's anyone's
fault if if they've been taught
everything incorrectly about how to take
care of themselves
uh i think they have some blame there
like you can't just be like i did what
other people told me to do so it's their
fault it's like dude you're a human
being people are stupid
stupid if a stupid person gets in a car
and then crashes it is it their fault of
course
but i read that i could love inside that
doesn't mean anything
you are responsible as the individual
yeah so as much as i agree with you
there are macro problems our food sucks
and people eat garbage yo i drive past
mcdonald's i see people in the
drive-through i don't understand it
legit have you ever taken a mcdonald's
burger bun and like split it open and
looked inside it looks like styrofoam
it's disgusting it's crazy wendy's is
not that bad i can't i can't stand it's
a potassium bromate i think i don't know
what it is banned in europe it doesn't
look and you ever see those things where
like they take the mcdonald's and they
put it in the room and leave it for a
month and it doesn't grow mold
yo i don't understand how people eat
that conservatives and it's expensive
yeah i i gotta tell you the one thing
about the pandemic that drives me i
blame the pharmaceuticals and uh the
politicians were just being cowards and
corrupt because they took all this money
they couldn't speak up you know but
if anything we should have gotten from
the pandemic was a discussion about
health you know and and and the fact
look covid um it could have taught us
something about being healthy and
co-morbidities and we just kind of
mulled right over that and and and
companies like mcdonald's and krispy
kreme who may who who contribute to the
problem you know had the audacity to
give away like a free doughnut or a free
meal oh yeah yeah if you went out and
got the message
i got to tell you everything i got no
issue with krispy kreme i don't eat it
it's pure sugar and starch you know
touch his own but i'm not doing it i'm
not gonna eat it but here's the idea you
know so uh i had i had a hot dog over
fourth of july i had a hot dog in a
burger that's bread
i've not been eating any bread i've not
been eating carbs or whatever but it's
fine if you have a burger and a hot
dog's no big deal the problem is people
take like 10 buns and like a whole dozen
krispy kremes and mash them together and
just eat them you know i went to a
restaurant in miami
they had a bread pudding i ordered it
and it was this stack of you know ever
you guys have had bread pudding yeah
yeah it sounds good delicious and i was
like this tastes like is this krispy
kreme yo they took like a dozen
doughnuts and then they make them
together
push it together into a small thing and
then glaze it and i was like
this is insane but working out tim you
know we didn't people don't they don't
know the benefits of being healthy diets
only one side of that and you can have
your you can have your starches in your
and your carbs if you balance it
correctly you take moderation and you
work out and i just started myself you
know i just hit that
that that four row period i'm like man
you better get in shape but before it's
too late you won't be able to do it
again um
and you know it's just a matter of it's
just a matter of statistics if you were
in better shape you had like you were at
less risk people people vitamin d
came out so many times i heard vitamin d
but i haven't heard like a concerted
push from the cdc or from anthony fauci
or from the government or any of it and
not vitamin d and sunlight and people
are very deficient yeah yeah yeah
absolutely especially people like um
from with like an african ancestry with
the darker with a lot of melatonin or it
was a melon and melon melon not
melatonin that makes you tired obviously
but it's because they require that skin
requires more sunlight just in general
that's what
so it needs more and if it has not as
much it gets more deficient quicker also
here's an article from fox8.com
coronavirus found on ice cream in china
all right let's talk about this let's
have a global discussion about
coronavirus living in and on food
it's a little symbolic at the beginning
of the pandemic when you there were all
those videos of people going into the
freezer aisle at grocery stores and like
licking the ice cream yeah that was such
a weird scion and then the crazy thing
was you had the one woman who did it she
got arrested then you had this one guy
who faked it and he thought it was funny
like i'm not really doing it and he
still got arrested
because they're like you don't
understand you're being arrested for
causing a panic not for licking the ice
cream right right because people now
won't buy it it causes a huge market
disruption yo she took the thing off the
ice cream licked it and put it back and
they didn't know where which walmart it
was so every walmart immediately got the
call like you got to throw all this ice
cream away
but i heard that she bought it after she
just did it for attention online right
but it doesn't matter
because they can sue her for that
oh for sure i mean there's no crime
right it is a crime yes what's the crime
so if you put out a video where you lick
a product and put it back no one knows
what product that was
so what happens is
a hundred thousand people watch that and
say i will not buy that ice cream
anymore and the store has no choice it's
almost like so it's also higher in the
credit let's say she has herpes we don't
know and she licks the ice cream puts it
back
the store because they don't see her
then pick it back up and buy it has to
assume every single ice cream is
contaminated and they have to throw away
at every store that has it
so it resulted in this massive purge of
all this ice cream and then she was like
it was a joke and they were like you you
contaminated a product by putting it
back in
you committed a crime
it cost the company i don't know how
many hundreds of thousands of dollars
i'd imagine what a waste cream what a
waste well walmart lost the money
because walmart so walmart sue her for
the lost money i don't know all i know
is people saw that and they were like
not realizing that it was a gag we're
like i'll do a gag and did the exactly
am i right that that was at the
beginning of kovid it was
i don't remember when though but i
remember being early on that's why it
became i also saw one with a woman
licking like macbook laptops that were
out on display and she was like licking
her hand and wiping the screen looking
at hanna white i'm sorry but society is
collapsing why is it that whenever
there's a video no but for real there's
a video of a he's not a good guy he
grabs his mouth he grabs mouthwash opens
it swishes with it spits it back and
puts it back on the shelf
people
are narcissistic psychopaths who want
likes and are doing insane things
without repercussion they're going
inside restaurants they're smashing
things up they just don't care anymore
nobody cares there's no community
there's no communal bonds there's no
fear there's no shame this is definitely
hyperbolic
i think there is a tendency towards that
now and it's addictive or or contagious
but there are a lot of people that want
structure and stability that just aren't
making idiot videos you see the idiocy
it's it's screaming it's louder this one
that screams as loud as you replace that
desire like something you said community
somebody said community if you replace
that with the human connection would
they stop doing that i mean are they are
they seeking these other more
destructive things because they don't
have those bonds and those those
connections maybe some people need
religion
so you're hearing jesus you hear
you hear a lot of uh secular people say
like
you need you know the ten commandments
to stop you from doing these things like
man that's scary and it's kind of like
maybe that's true for some people yeah
maybe there are a lot of people of you
know higher brain function who are like
you know i don't want to hurt you
because i don't want someone to hurt me
and i respect these laws and maybe there
are a lot of people who just don't know
don't care and need
i think they need a code of ethics and
they need community but they don't
necessarily need an organized religion
they need fear of social us uh ostracism
yeah and kids should know that from an
early age i used to have my my
privileges taken away by my parents if i
did something wrong said something i
wasn't supposed to say did something i
was supposed to do i lost all my
privileges i or i couldn't watch tv
couldn't play video games i had to sit
in my room alone and quiet they were
they were teaching me if you go into
society and you screw people they're
going to seize your privileges in
society but there's levels to why people
don't do bad things right like fear is
just the lowest level but
ultimately our goal should be that they
want the good well like what you said i
don't want someone to do it listen
listen
right now
the incentive is to do bad
the bad things get you views getting
rewarded get you likes and could even
make you famous and rich
so the people are going out and they're
doing horrifying things online because
it's working for them
yo you know what really pisses me off
i've been skateboarding most of my life
and i see these videos go viral get
shared by pros of people fighting
security guards and i'm like get that
off instagram dude
there was a security guard who got put
into his he i think he died some do went
to prison because these these
skateboarders they always make these
videos where they go and skate a street
spot like a private
private property the security guard
comes out and says hey you got to leave
and they're like nah and then they'll
like shove the security guard or the
fight with them that's what they do and
they go viral and people are like oh
there are also videos where the security
guard goes like one more try and they'll
be like yeah and they'll try one more
time but whenever you get these videos
where they're fighting with security
guards that pisses me off
what you're supposed to do in your
skating a security guard says leave you
leave you say okay i'm sorry you leave
you come back when you're not bothering
somebody but this guy these guys were
skating i think it was an sf and
security guard came out and said you got
to leave
and so someone shoved him and then the
security guard took a swing at another
guy who then shoved him and he fell down
hit his head
i think he died
and so that skateboarder who was
committing a crime and attacked somebody
went to prison well
he went to prison but the problem is
these videos are still on instagram they
still glorify this stuff and they always
have it's it you know it was rare back
in the day watching the jackass stuff
those guys were like picking on each
other but there were elements of that
where they would screw with other people
and then the whole prank culture started
to expand and get crazier and crazier
where you had the people just like going
up to random people and screaming at
them and just doing the craziest things
youtube started to get rid of all this
stuff but you look at what's happening
now with the licking ice cream you look
at these videos like the nurse being
like i lost a patient oh my life
people are psychotic narcissists you
think that people need an enemy to fight
i don't know about needing an enemy but
people want meaning
you know or right
meaning yeah people but i think
look there's obviously
varying tiers of
let's just say perspicacity there are
some people who are as dumb as a box of
rocks we know some people are stupid
some people are smart
there are some people who are just as
basic as they come they want attention
and they don't care how they get it then
there are people who are just of a
higher moral um
for whatever reason moral standing where
they're just like i don't want to do
that i have scruples that makes me feel
bad doing that but some people don't
have that some people don't have that
conscience for whatever reason and
they're the ones who are going to go out
and make a video mocking the dead
dancing on the graves look at the tick
tock nurses yeah dancing on the graves
of the coveted victims and people on the
left praised them and they got mad at me
when i said that i was like dude there's
a guy dying right there and these nurses
are doing these shuffle dances and their
excuses like oh they're using humor as a
coping mechanism for all of the tragedy
around them like no they just think it's
a laughing matter that you know that you
don't care yeah your family members are
in their care and there's a video where
you actually see patients filming
and there's people shuffle dancing and
then the people who are act like so so
they're filming a bit but the video
itself is from a patient going is this
why we can't get any help right now is
this why we're not getting taken care of
and they're filming the tick tock nurses
doing their tick-tock dances
if i i swear man all those people should
have been fired
but some but our culture is is fractured
sick i'd tell you this man if i worked
at a hospital if i was a boss at a
hospital and i walked in and saw shuffle
dancing i'd be like each and every one
of you get out in defense of the nurses
it'd be like if they were like in trauma
situation and like in the military when
the military platoon makes a kill you
know in the horror of war there have
been people at least they have friends
of mine their soldiers will say humorous
gets used to to cope
well yeah and that's true and the
sergeant won't fire them all on the spot
but i don't know if we can equate that
to that i mean i
and also i would say that that's never
going to happen because we have such a
few short shortages of healthcare people
you know they're allowed to they they
can't even even worse nurse shortage
yeah there was before and it's only
getting worse but we do have to go to
super chats we're a little behind if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel and become a member at
timcast.com to help us ramp up
production on a bunch of new shows i saw
someone mention they said tim you talk
about food shortages and all this stuff
why don't you do a show on survival and
guarding gardening we are preparing that
we uh being out here in the middle of
nowhere we know a lot of people who know
all the hidden secrets of eating
dandelions and wine berries and pawpaw
raising chickens and goats a lot of
farmers good people and so we're
actually talking about doing like a 13
episode series which is going to be fun
funny and teach you how to
be more self-reliant because uh
i don't know the end is nigh
dandelions are delicious
absolutely i've never had that they're
delicious my wife that dandelion tea
yeah you know those green onions yeah um
yeah you just let them grow i don't know
what she does there's something you got
to do to do it it triggers a flower to
come up mm-hmm eat that flower it's
delicious we got it we got to read some
super chats
all right james eaton says what are your
thoughts on predictive policing the
institute of justice released a video
this morning about it happening in
florida yeah i saw this story it said
algorithms can predict when crime is
going to happen a week in advance
yup i don't like it machines don't have
emotions and emotions are a lot of the
reason of why crimes are committed but
what if
a report came out and said
there's going to be robberies in these
neighborhoods next week so all they did
was send out cops to stop the robberies
oh
oh okay not quite minority report
full-blown using it as an advisor is a
different story one day you walk outside
and there's like there's like three cops
on the corner and you're like what's
going on and they're like
algorithm predicted this would be a hot
spot this weekend so we're just here to
make sure everyone's okay but okay cool
yeah be like if you're driving your
car's like warning speeding vehicle
approaching from the northwest you're
like okay and you stop and then 13
seconds later a car goes flying like i'm
okay with that kind of ai or like you're
driving your car and then all of a
sudden you're like i gotta i gotta go
the bathroom starts speeding and then
the car goes i can't let you do that ian
the car slows down
but would you be worried about a
slippery slope with that so it one
minute it goes from an advanced version
of comstats the next minute it does turn
into minority sure if the code's private
if it's a proprietary code which is the
first step you gotta make the code open
source if you're gonna use this kind of
stuff because it can go haywire in
secret not open source at all all right
let's read some more we got beavis
mclean says hr 4310 national defense
authorization act authorized propaganda
on american citizens is this why we have
so much fake news and why dems
immediately moved to dissuade elon from
buying twitter curious your take i don't
think you needed the ndaa to have
companies do this they make money doing
it they've always done this it's just
worse now and we can see it
all right raymond g magastanley jr from
magamonth says the gas is a rising the
price is so high our oil reserves bound
up to dry old man speaks a letter to psy
after next election it's biden bye-bye
hey beautiful poetry we got a new song
huh
all right sage of rokaseka says herbert
kersten was not a globalist he was just
a conservationist with some
controversial
ideas i know there's a missing word
though popular controversial though
popular ideas in those circles in the
70s 80s so people are saying that's who
actually built it well a lot of people
don't like those things man
all right let's grab some more super
chutes
jay says a language that unites people
already exists in theory music
i believe that is incorrect there's
kinds of music that people don't like we
had andrew clavin on the show and he
told me that rap was not music and i
said well of course it is he's like no
it isn't
and it's just i'm like i don't
understand why you don't think rap is
music that just doesn't make sense it's
a weird hill to die on yeah uh i'm not a
fan of world of music have you guys ever
listened have you ever listened to world
music
and like i love them
that just goes to prove it though just
because you may not like he may not like
rap i know um there's still music yeah
see here's the thing yeah like world
music people say like i don't like rap
and i'm like are you talking about like
gangster rap and like bling bling stuff
because you ever listen to like some
real rap thought-provoking stuff some
good stuff from back in the day or even
stuff now there's good rap
it exists you gotta get some good music
going on right
guardsman norheim of the 10th first says
the guidestones where did you say luke
went
that's strange
luke did mention driving south and i did
ask him if it was an inside job
hmm luke is mysteriously absent
[Music]
luke rudkowski the only way for him to
clear his name is to come back on the
show
luke
all right friendly neighborhood sawyer
says could the living language mentioned
in the guidestones be some kind of
technological telepathy maybe neural
link based you know yes but there are
these there when we read that i thought
of something though tim there are these
people who do
believe in this um
where it's like maybe the word doesn't
even mean the word it changes and you're
just supposed to know
i don't i'm not sure what it's called
but these people also think they're
communicating with different entities
that aren't on the same wavelength so
but that's what they called it living
something and when you read that i
thought about that i'm like
it has that been that old
you know that was erected in 1980
have these people been doing this all
that time i thought that was somewhat
new it was crazy um yeah i don't know
all right we got hendrix 88 says on june
28th alejandro morena the current leader
of mexico's pri political party proposed
legalizing firearms for civilians
following a shooting at a covet jab site
in puebla mexico
tweet is at alito moreno c i thought you
might want to know research very
interesting very interesting take a look
all right we got what is this atomic
says tim i was a breacher for usmc the
placement for that explosive was amateur
a pro would have known how to direct th
the overpressure and enhance it
that's yeah yeah yeah i feel like the
blast they could have taken that whole
thing out if they did it right
the maybe the device was right but the
placement was wrong
all right el
eldritchinator says one genocide two
eugenics three newspeak four no religion
or tradition five equity ideology six
new world order nw over sovereignty
seven no nations eight no individual
rights nine grandstanding ten humans
cancer to be abated woof
as a brutal breakdown of what those
stones represent huh
yikes
all right let's let's grab some more
super chats
uh uh el bossert says tim crowder will
be in west virginia the weekend of
october 8th for a stand-up gig can you
try to book him on irl for that friday
also reach out to youtuber mishako he's
a gun reviewer who is blind crowder will
be in charleston which is what six hours
away that's correct yeah like six hours
away so uh also
so i guess he's coming this way yeah he
is sure is all right crowder that means
you have to do it
yeah that would be awesome that would be
absolutely amazing we have dave on next
week gotta talk about it oh that's cool
that's right
we're revealing the secrets of our guest
book secrets
quorition says barris i'm a huge fan i
try to watch all your shows have you
done a poll on how people in new mexico
feel about the leadership not certifying
the election
uh thanks by the way but um
no and it's not because of the topic or
anything i just new mexico i'm like a
bit of a skeptic on new mexico being
battleground it's younger it's not so
even though we're seeing this hispanic
vote shift the population itself is
younger what what what happened with
that so it was a democrat it was it was
a primary
and they the the court said you have to
certify and said no yeah and i i wonder
why it's it what it is might i'm sure it
grabs attention it grabs a lot of
people's attention there's just seems to
be different standards tim you know
with how they react in georgia there was
a minor mistake a woman had caught i
mean her own ballot wasn't counted in
her own precinct so she got a whole new
count
and it changed the result so
random eskimos says 2024 prediction
biden runs against trump mid-september
to mid-october biden has a sad end
then uh the ds
the dumb democrats push out a vote a
sentiment an emotion
i don't know maybe here's what i was
thinking there's reports that trump is
going to announce his run early
i think that would be the smartest
possible thing he can do for two reasons
there's two potential scenarios first
donald trump announces he's running
joe biden's already said he is so trump
can come out and be like i am running
against joe biden
joe biden has two options quit because
he's too old or
actually go up against trump
if joe biden quits
then trump's going to be like i already
beat biden yeah he's quitting he's
bailing out can you trust the democrats
to have the strength to lead this nation
joe biden can stay in the race with all
his abysmal failures and ratings never
going to happen or trump can hope that
he gets the he's running
before anything bad happens to biden
because biden's already well past his
average life expectancy
if biden
comes to a uh peaceful and as an old man
as it as his age could predict donald
trump can just be like it's a very sad
day it's very sad i'm you know you know
joe has many things
who's gonna run
it just no matter what happens it looks
really really bad for democrats do you
think there's any chance trump will run
not as a republican no he's a republican
yeah and not not this time if there was
some real big split in the republican
party which could have there was there
was a moment there that could have
happened uh then maybe we would have
went down that road but he should
announce early number and and two you
scare everybody else away
yeah any other republicans all right
generally irritable says instead of
talking that national divorce nonsense
help me restore federalism i'm running
for the lone congressional seat in
vermont and i am a constitutional
conservative
reddick for congress dot com that is
james lindsay's friend oh he texted me
and told me that she was going to super
chat in i was like that oh okay awesome
well there you go it's uh
rvdic for congress.com we'll take a look
at that we're uh we're a little uh
we're primed for another james lindsay
visit yeah well yeah james come out
james rogers says i'm 32 classical
liberal and i'm ashamed to inform you
that i will be voting republican this
upcoming election even if it's trump
giving our gas away did it i'm a sailor
and i love my country that's just i
don't understand how anyone could be
looking at the gas and then be like oh
yeah biden took our strategic reserves
and exported 5 million barrels it's not
like 5 million you know a whole lot
still relative
but it's like it's like a little bit
more than one percent of our reserves
that's kind of cool it's a nice slap
yeah it's a nice slide it's like he's
laughing at you and he does it that blew
my mind i looked for the story i didn't
see anything from abc nbc cbs on it of
course not anything because there's a
bunch of it's a new york post article
the new york post is pretty and
washington
on timecast.com yeah
but i mean the liberal economic orders
media apparatus doesn't seem to be
explaining what's going on here ignoring
that well that's right
someone is contested
i also see five million barrels and 50
million barrels which is it five or
fifty five he exported fifty who's no
that's an old story
says tim if she was gen z she looks too
old for being 17
the first year of gen z burst with twos
and five that's uh i believe it's not
correct i don't think that's true yeah
um we've talked about it quite a bit
1996
yeah and there's uh um
i think the the youngest millennials
right now are 26 or 27. yeah we're age
and up yeah it's the youngest
millennials and then anything younger
than that is considered gen z but a lot
of people have different opinions on
when generations started yeah yeah
i'm on the line where
b z or x
right 40.
right so oh right right right yes
yeah yeah the mixture okay is it a
generation y no generation y is morning
yes okay yeah yeah
millennials are also called echo boomers
that sounds way cooler yeah it sounds
cool yeah boomer no it doesn't does it
cool yeah it's way cool cool
do you even watch anime
all right
hunterkiller86 says it has to do with
the petrodollar notice how the euro and
pound has gone down since february but
the usd stays the same it's all the
petro dollar scam
i would not be surprised my friends
adam townsend says i heard the oil
exported could have been sour crude but
our processing plants handle sweet crude
due to all the fracking in recent
history we can't process sour
efficiently any longer
it could be and i will point this out
too we you got to be careful
about some of these stories about you
know biden canceled an oil lease and
then everyone's like why did he do that
then you find out like a court ordered
it so it's not like he chose to do it
and this could be due to sour crew or
whatever but uh i'm just gonna pause and
say i will not give them the benefit of
the doubt if they don't come out and
explain it and even if they did i
probably still wouldn't trust them this
dude has done so much to tank this
country and i
anybody who's saying otherwise is just
lying to themselves at the very least
you can say the man is incompetent and
is fumbling around worst case scenarios
it looks like it's on purpose but there
is no reasonable circumstance where
biden is just you know doing all these
good things that just aren't helping
that would be crazy to me
chris fendley says do the pollsters
consider false answers from people
trying to mess with the poll accuracy
yeah we do try that
um well some of us do
and that's why it's important like when
i'm mocked on yougov before saying
they're not even a voter a voter file
source panel because you have no other
attributes to collect against these
people if you know an 18 to 24 year old
african-american girl from you know
inner philadelphia it told you she's
going to vote republican she's lying you
know that but if there are other data
attributes that are on that file and you
can actually prove that and be confident
then you can it's it's not clean data
and you could get rid of it um i try to
lean towards believing people though i
do because and the reason why you may
miss them change their mind it's
possible
right on ed abell says or abel says tim
are you working on an app for xbox slash
smart tv
yes here's the challenge
it takes a lot of time and money
seriously so um we've been working we're
trying to
we can only grow as fast as we can grow
um money isn't necessarily the answer
it's people
we want to do our mobile apps obviously
iphones people usually do iphone first
because you build an iphone app it
basically works for all the iphone
platforms but you build android you got
all these different android platforms
you got to make like 20 30 different
versions of the app then if you want to
do smart tvs you got to get approval
from the tvs so i think that may be why
uh daily wire is like apple roku and
chrome but i don't know if they're on
smart tvs it may be because you have to
get approved by them that's what we're
aiming for and so we're going to be
doing a bunch of shows that are just
going to appear on timecast.com so that
if you're a member you'll get a bigger
and bigger library because we want to
displace things like netflix and disney
plus because they produce awful garbage
that's bad for you and your family and
your kids and we want to create things
that are just kind of politically
neutral and if there is a message it'll
be like freedom and responsibility and
not much more than that
we're also um we've we've got some kids
shows in the pipeline
obviously uh chicken city if you've seen
it is very family friendly and we have a
bunch of stuff in in the pipeline it
just we're not as big as the daily wire
but we will be maybe by next year we'll
have like three or four shows on the
website with your support by becoming a
member at timcast.com we'll do it faster
the real issue is finding good people
and it is money i mean obviously we can
only hire so many people and the more we
can hire the better the faster we can
move into the directions the
documentaries are expensive people need
to understand these documentaries can
cost between 100 and like 500 000 if you
want to do it well
i wonder how much daily wire put into
what is a woman because i got to imagine
there's probably several hundred
thousand dollars to produce that because
it was really well done
but uh yeah support our work if you
wanna help let's read some more super
chats
all right rando bunderson says doesn't
matter if michelle is as good as lefties
think she is she ruined my school
lunches it's a no for me
what did she do that was very uh she
made them healthy and i only know this
uh you can say family member uh
yeah she basically took what would be
tasty and made it like cardboard well
i mean there's still garbage anyway i
look
it depends where you are really you know
state like north carolina i find those
to be underwhelming and they're still
trying to you know to um
meet her guidelines yeah in florida they
did and they were delicious i don't
understand sugar to be completely honest
you know like so the sugar that i was
mostly eating when i was eating was
grains and so i cut out the rice and the
bread yeah but i love fat right avocados
sour cream cheese
bacon grease just poured all over
everything
it's it's just i like it better
i could i could i could take a bowl of
sour cream and just spoon it it's so
good
i don't i don't understand like the
sugary stuff like cakes either i don't
like cake do you like cake of course i
like i don't you don't like yourself a
good molten lime no cake nope not a fan
i would rather have like
an ice cream or something something you
know that is better than cake yeah cake
i just i mean cake is kind of fatty but
i'm just not a fan of that
the fats and the sugars
the best in moderation
you got to be accurate about what kind
of because glucose is super important
it's a sugar it's sugar it's a simple
sugar everyone needs it but the sugar
industry is like yeah it's just call
everything sugar no no no your sucrose
that you're pushing on people is poison
totally different sucrose
yeah fructose is bad
this is funny when people say like fruit
is good for you it's got fructose and
it's fruit sugar and i'm like bro have
you ever read about fructose your body
can't use it's got to be processed in
the liver it's very intensive yeah
without the the fiber
of the fruit so when they make fruit
juice you get the still the fructose but
without the fiber of the fruit it goes
right into the liver like sucrose
converts it into fat
um and it's this refinement process i
don't know a lot about dude high
fructose corn syrup when you read you go
to dao the company dow the chemical
production company they make that stuff
in vats and they use like a resin like i
think it's arsenic resin don't quote me
on this and see if you can find how to
make high fructose and if you can send
it to me on twitter because i want to go
deep it was buried in the dao industrial
website when i was looking for a reason
no doubt yeah it's disgusting and then
they don't have to put the cleaning
agent in the ingredients because it's
used as a cleaning agent like the the
arsenic or whatever it is all right we
got loki tomes says hey tim hey tim cast
i'm a 23 year old otr truck driver i've
worked for the same company for two and
a half years but last night the company
went under i'm friendly with the owner
and asked what happened he said lack of
drivers low priced loads and high gas
prices bankrupted him i guess i'm going
to use this as an excuse to move to
florida thanks for the shows appreciate
the very large super chat
cletus christ says
zimmerman didn't follow martin he was
walking to the cross street in the
apartment complex as instructed by
dispatch and encountered martin on the
way
watch the trial this was my red pill
moment crazy
so much of its lies
man the ahmed armory case lie
5 29 insurrection remember that one yeah
529
i'm aware of the insurrection i believe
they burned a church they tried to torch
st john's church they tried raiding uh
assaulting the white house
setting fire to a guard post and the
media mocked him for coming out there
with beau barr they mocked trump for
being forced into an emergency bunker
during an insurrection
terrifying i mean literally terrifying
if you think about it and just this
morning i saw someone on the street with
a sign that's like only we can stop more
trump coup attempts
what like your brain is just
so poisoned yeah it's just sad
like come back to reality
1776's life says tim you've given plenty
of warnings about food shortages why
don't you do a complete podcast
dedicated to gardening hunting and food
preservation we are going to do a show
that uh has all of that so if you're a
member at tim cast we are hoping to
actually get it started soon you gotta
understand too it's not super difficult
to do something like that we got all
these right wing nut jobs who live up on
the mountain in uh in west virginia and
we say that endearingly they call
themselves that and um
oh they know everything they're like
here's what like they live out here
they're like here's what you do we got
raccoon problem here's how you take care
of your trash chickens oh we can tell
you how to do the chickens it's fair to
call me a prepper oh nice
yeah i think it's fair to call me a
pepper i don't think tell me about your
prep i don't think crazy food i got uh
out back eventually the goal is to just
be able to you know at least vegetables
um and certain you know well i mean if
you call tomatoes or fruit i mean but
yeah um you know to be able to to have
something throughout each season to put
right to the table and i have the space
for it at least that we think we do
people have always done this it's so
funny that prepper is a derogatory term
now like oh you prepare things but
what's wrong with you
guys
you know with the barrels um we have we
do have food though tim like the food
that lasts like 30 years oh i got we got
tons of people do jar and canned food
you know what we were we did for a while
until she found an alternative which is
you know we're working on that now but
uh yeah we want to look we're gonna
we're disposable because i'm interested
you know we'll see if it works first
thank you
we made jams last year with the wine
berries yeah so wine berries are crazy
down here every so it's wineberry season
it's amazing when i'm coming up so i i
ride my electric motorcycle to come here
we just stop along the edge and just eat
i think i had maybe like 50 of them
they're just so good the wild
raspberries yeah the picture with like a
net connected to your bike and just like
just kind of cascades
yeah he's got but people got to eat them
because they they they go bad and they
fall off and then we need to
that's the key so we made preserves last
year was amazing i made lemon wine berry
and wineberry jam and we saved them for
months and it was amazing they last a
long time incredible mulberries too the
mulberries are all over the place you
got to save the mulberries yeah because
you walk up to the tree and you shake it
you put it we put a tarp under the tree
you do one big shake and you've got like
that's a good five pounds of multiparts
that's a good idea yeah i don't even
think of that yeah we took a sheet we
laid it down under the tree and we
grabbed the branch and just shook it and
then we had about a bowl and then we uh
we blended it up with some lemon juice
and some sugar and boiled it down and
made jam and sealed it up put on the
shelf
and then we have paw paws in october so
right beginning of october it's just an
endless stream of paw paw i should say i
i'm very hard on sugar because it's the
overeating of sugar that's the problem a
small dose of sugar like that can keep
you alive for a long time
all right there's value to it let's grab
a couple more super chips before we go
to that members only
all right let's see
jack plimer says i heard the guidestone
destroyed was the side with russian and
chinese writing the intention was
possibly not to destroy the whole
monument but send a political message
maybe
i don't know that's interesting
[Music]
thrawn fett says build a new georgia
guide stones and just put the
constitution on a granite slab no one
knows who made it so no copyright amen
and great marking for tim kest uh i'm
down can we do that yes we can let's
legit do that
uh how many pages of the constitution
it's not that big right it's not very
long seven we're talking about the first
yeah the bill of rights the articles
well the the the first the constitution
plus the bill of rights
oh we'll do all the amendments we gotta
do it and we'll like legit let's do
let's see if it's prohibitively
expensive i won't but if we can get that
done and put it up at free damastan big
granite slabs the constitution all
written out i'm so downfield i wanna
make it interactable for kids somehow
with like a magnifying glass that can
slide around on it wow
okay we can add another for the ten
commandments
well you can do all that that's all you
do um if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel tell your friends about
the show if you really do like it
because that's how we've gotten to this
point has been all word of mouth uh
we've only recently started doing more
marketing and we're gonna do a lot more
as we expand we need your support at
timcast.com because we're gonna start
producing a bunch of shows um so let me
let me let me tell you guys about tales
from the inverted world the new season
is out
it is
i think this season each episode is like
22 minutes long
shane cashman went down to georgia and
investigated the lost uh confederate
gold
uh ufos all the weird stuff that came
along with it witches
and um
you know the difficulty is how do we
maintain a show like that we have to
produce something and we have to you
know sell it so uh what we're going to
be doing is second episode will come up
free the first episode will be free and
then the show will be a timcast.com
exclusive
because we want to start
trying to grow the business and we can't
just make stuff that's expensive for
free so considering the production
quality and the cost i was like let's
just have this be a show for members and
try and build up more members by doing
more awesome shows like this but we will
be launching another show with shane
cashman it's like hunter s thompson
meets the x-files he's going to be doing
conversations on
more regularly regularly occurring uh
news as opposed to just a deeper
investigation so we'll have the deeper
investigation show which is seasonal
which could be i think it's like 13
episodes plus the weekly conversational
show that's 52 episodes and then we're
actually building a new set at our
haunted house location which is an old
house from the 1800s where he's going to
be filming that new show so i'm really
excited for all this so your support
will help make that happen plus we're
working on the survival show where we do
um educational breakdowns on
what's like living out in the middle of
nowhere how to get water how to clean
water how to grow food all that good
stuff so uh support us at timcast.com
smash the like button follow us at tim
cast irl and you can follow me at tim
cast uh the people's pundit do you want
to shout anything out yeah i mean people
can follow me on uh people's
pundit.locals.com that's the community
the locals community uh but of course
too
you know what if you really want to
check it out bigdatapoll.com scroll to
the down at the bottom and you'll see
all the trackers we do for the public
polling project and i'll tell you what
if you follow polls if you want to know
what real clear politics is going to say
two weeks from a m or a month from now
follow us at the public polling project
because we lead them it's been like this
for almost two years now the point of it
is to just be transparent and i think we
can get more trust back in this industry
if we're just a little bit more open
about how we do things and that's the
entire goal of that uh that project so
yeah check it out at bigdatapoll.com at
the bottom and then locals community is
the best place where i aggregate
everything right on
if you want to see me more often you can
find me on instagram or wechat at closer
kitty and also go subscribe to pop
culture crisis on youtube we go live
every monday through friday at 3 p.m
eastern time and noon pacific time so
come join us this week is a little bit
different we're posting a pre-recorded
episode on friday
uh you guys follow me ian crossland.net
get in touch with me on social media
youtube twitter minds facebook instagram
twitch it goes on and on anywhere you
can think to find someone on social
media you'll probably find me there rich
barris great to see you man you as well
good conversation very good i like yeah
special indeed thanks a lot dude see you
later my pleasure i just want to read
one last super chat i said tim do me a
favor tell chris you did a good job
yesterday that's from audrey absolutely
uh andrew sorry and i have to say thank
you very much to chris for letting me
take a day just to try not to die i
really appreciated it i was glad to not
have to worry about coming in and
being sick on the show so yes very much
thank you chris for doing that for me
you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at starpatchlids as
well as soundpatchlids.me
we will see all of you at timcast.com
for that members only show coming up at
11 pm thanks for hanging out bye guys
you